all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel
today we are going to be talking about
it's a call-in show
okay
now as you know
sometimes
occasionally
my call-in shows get a little off topic
i'm going to do my best to stay on the
topic tonight which is crazy dating
stories
have you ever dated someone
married have you ever dated someone that
was just using you for your money
have you ever dated someone that was
batshit crazy
i'm gonna tell you guys
oh my gosh the craziest dating story
i don't even know if i want to tell this
on the air
okay
do i should i tell it
should i
[Music]
i don't know maybe not maybe not that
one
because because i do think this guy was
like a nice guy a good person
and
i i don't want him to be salty that i i
said this on my youtube channel
but it's a very funny story
it's very funny it's like hilarious some
would say
oh my gosh
hold on hold on one second
um one second one second i need to i'm
gonna feed my dog i just realized i
don't think i fed her hold up hold up
ellie
ellie are you hungry
okay
[Music]
okay i'm back
sorry
sorry
okay okay okay
um you know what i feel like you guys
need to work for this story i'm not
gonna lie to you
i'm gonna need like 50 people in this in
this chat room
on live before i tell this story because
i'm not going to give it to you guys for
nothing i'm sorry so like the video
put some comments in the chat let's get
50 people in here and i'll tell it
but
oh my gosh i'm getting anxiety just
thinking about this because this was oh
this is crazy but i'm gonna give you
guys
wait wait what does this say i once
dated a wild wolverine found it to be
friendlier than most girls okay
or
or hear me out of 50 super chat
i don't know i don't make maybe that's
too much maybe that's too much i don't
know
guys you have to understand this was a
good story i told this story the other
day
amongst my friends
people were laughing look if you don't
think it's worth it that's fine
don't get people in here don't
oh my gosh
anyways i'm gonna continue with this
live so
everyone's had a crazy dating story
everyone you can't have dated and not
had a crazy dating story unless story
unless
you met your your significant other at
like
15 or something
i'll tell you a different one
one time one time
um
one time what's up
trying to think i've been a ghoster okay
i have i have ghosted i personally i
have a rule about ghosting and you guys
can let me know in the chat if you agree
i think
i think that
look it that can be five dollars towards
the 50 i'm trying to raise to tell the
story
look it you have to understand when i
tell this story it comes at a cost to me
anyone can watch it that's embarrassing
now i really shouldn't have started it
off because i really thought i was going
to tell it until i started to think of
the consequences of telling it
yeah but okay back to back to what i was
talking about i do think that ghosting
is okay if you've gone on a date or less
do i think it's the mature thing to do
no of course not of course not
but
like if i barely know you
i met you one time
um
am i saying i'm haunted
i'm not saying i'm haunted but sometimes
when guys meet me
they put me on this pedestal that i just
can't live up to i'm not gonna lie
i'm just i'm just being honest
and i don't mean to have them do that
but it's just like what
am i like sometimes like i think you
need to
humble me a little bit like i'm not that
anyways
i'm trying to think one time this guy it
was so weird um
he basically tried to like get physical
with me faster than i wanted to
and i just
that really really turns me off that
really i don't like that i don't it's
not
it's not cute when i tell you no and you
keep pushing it i i don't like that
this guy so i asked him to leave
my apartment because i was like maybe i
shouldn't have hung out with him there i
don't know but
because i was just like look i i know
that's what you had in mind that's not
what i had in mind i thought we were
just getting to know each other i guess
anyways
anyways this guy
i kick him out and
i just tell him you know it's just
better that we're just friends because
he lived in my building at the time this
is why you shouldn't
date people in your building you
shouldn't
and it was so random one night i dropped
my wallet and he found it so he messages
me and it's like oh i have your wallet
someone up to get it and
i talked to him for a little bit i'm a
chit chatter guys i really like to talk
that's what i'm talking to myself right
now
anyways
um
so
he
i leave and he messages me and he says i
was so nice talking to you like maybe we
could go on a date again or something
and i just i don't want to give him any
hope
i'm not going to go on another date with
you sir i'm just being honest
and so i said
you know what i think it'd just be
better for your friends and mind you
mind you
this man was the self-proclaimed like
male feminist so you would think he
would be cool
with me saying no you know what i mean
anyways he messages me back and says
never contact me again
i was like damn that escalated so
quickly i feel like the men in the chat
will be like that's an alpha
i don't i don't really care
but
that's before this last dating story
that i don't want to tell you guys
that was my craziest dating story cause
i really haven't had anything that crazy
happened to me
to be honest before or before the last
one
um because i'm trying to think anything
else like super nuts
and that wasn't even that nuts it was
just
i don't know it's just
weird
this was because
that's what he said on our date when we
went on he like told me he's a male
feminist and i was like
i know that probably wins you points
with most girls but not me i'm not gonna
lie to you i there's nothing that made
me like
faster and
he also
i don't know
he i forgot what he said he said
something
weird something weird on the date that
was like he asked me if i believed in
population control and i was like no
not particularly
and then he was arguing with me
about
population control like do you feel this
strongly sir
about population control of all things
this is what you want to talk about
he was nice we got along really well
and i probably would have liked him if
it wasn't
the male feminist that i just
there's a lot of girls that
will that will win you points for i'm
not even gonna lie to you
a lot
but not me i'm that's i'm not that [ __ ]
i'm not
it's not me
um
oh my gosh this is a funny story this
isn't this is this is crazy actually one
time a while ago i forgot i did this
because this is when i was like 22. i
thought it would be funny to go on
dating apps and have guys
have to be interviewed with my mom
before they could go on a date with me
oh my gosh it was so funny so
there is like how many guys did it i
think three guys that did it it was so
funny i wonder if i still have that
video
the video was so ass to be honest it was
so ass
um
[Music]
i didn't really know how to do youtube
back then or really
how do i put it
oh no
okay
i forgot what i was talking about oh oh
yeah and so then
this is a problem yeah then there's
three guys one guy lived really far so
it didn't really make sense like he was
only in chicago for
a certain amount of time but i would
just copy and paste the message because
you guys know how it is for females on
dating apps like i don't care so i would
just copy and paste copy and paste copy
and paste it was very funny
oh my sister just texted me
do i know who matthew hussey is yes i do
matthew hussey is a female dating coach
guys call in okay i think the link is in
the description to call in but i want to
hear your your crazy dating stories
i want to hear them
um
i do want i do want to tell this dating
story i really do because it's really
funny
but the consequences that's what i keep
thinking about i would hate for
oh gosh i would hate i would hate for
the people
involved in this story to see it i would
really hate that
i'm trying to think my friends if any of
my friends have crazy dating stories
they've told me
um
trying to think my friends have crazy
dating stories
[Music]
actually let me see let me see if i can
facetime a friend and see if they will
answer and tell me a crazy dating story
let's see
tell us don't use real names i know but
this is the problem the bigger you get
this is the problem the people involved
see it and then they text you and they
have a problem with it
when you're smaller you don't have to
worry about that nobody sees your stuff
you you have to beg people to see your
stuff basically
okay let's let's
hi marcus
hey how are you how's everything
i'm good how are you
good good how's the uk
it's good i love it here
did you guys win your game last time i
know you posted a game like yesterday or
two days ago
yeah my battery died so i couldn't post
the end but yeah we won
yeah it's always freezing every time
like you're in the middle of the game it
freezes
yeah we got a lot of issues with the
games because
yeah they're we're working on it it's
going to get better but there's some
issues with the streaming on my end
okay
let me just close the door
so what's the topic for the day on your
stream oh yeah what's your craziest
dating story
uh
[ __ ]
well not only do i have some but i have
other people as well but um
start off with mine either okay go ahead
okay
all right well it's it's also not just a
dating more like a hookup
as well okay so it was like okay so
it'll it'll curly so this girl that i
got a number right
i was uh at a at a market store or
grocery store i got her number
she had this whole like mill for cougar
look to her
so i go and and and i get a number this
is about like five six years ago
um the first time that we end up meeting
up
it was on a sunday
and you're probably gonna it was right
after church and she calls me to meet up
and then i go to our place we hook up
for the first time and it's literally
our first time hanging out after i got
her number
uh then she texts me later and she says
hey hey um
make sure you delete the text or
something like that he's like why i'm
like what i need to delete it
and she's like oh i'm married by the way
yeah she didn't tell me this because she
didn't have a ring on or nothing because
i i whenever i look for a girl i see
certain social cues and like physical
cues so i checked her hand so she has to
be taking it off more than once
because it didn't really have a ring
print but she had the ring
but she didn't have it on and
i was wondering because i went um we
were living not that far from each other
like maybe a couple blocks and from
different
apartments at the time
and i went to her place we hooked up and
then
uh yeah she just texted me that and i
remember telling my friend about that
i'm like
oh i got
no i didn't know but i still feel like
bad i still felt a little like the bad
feeling inside because i don't ever like
to do that i never mess with every any
man's woman or wife it's especially wife
and he has like she's like yeah like
she's married and i was like why don't
you just tell me you were married in the
first place
so this whole time that i got her number
and everything and then we were texting
for a little bit and then all of a
sudden that happens
and it was funny because like about like
about a month like couple months later
i see her
i had to go visit my mom in the hospital
and she's there with her man
no
yeah but i went around so like she saw
me i saw her but we kind of avoided each
other but
that happened
do you know
hopefully it's not a pregnancy because i
kind of i didn't wear a condom
no oh gosh wait so um
you're probably one of many you know
what i mean
hopefully not i hope not i hope not not
for him i hope not if not
i don't know what are the odds that like
the one day she decides to hook up with
the guy that got her number at the
grocery store the first time
that she met with him
like what what are the odds that you
were the only guy she did that with
probably not probably others
yeah
and then it's weird cause like a few
weeks later i saw her at the hospital
like
hopefully she wasn't getting a paternity
test or like a
a maybe ultrasound or something
yeah that's that's nuts did you you
didn't see her again after that did you
we hooked up another time after that but
it was a while after though and i
she said she was um she said she was
supposedly single but
then she kind of i think tells me the
same thing later
yeah i mean she did it the first time
that's crazy though that she didn't tell
you she was married did she have kids or
anything like a whole family or just a
husband
i i think it was just a husband because
i didn't see any pictures of like
i didn't pay attention i'm sorry i'm
gonna say that again i just wasn't
paying attention i was just trying to do
my thing with her
we were just talking reviving and then
she was acting weird because after we
smashed it's like if i was the um what's
that term
like the
the booty call like i feel like the
booty call
and she basically just got me out
basically i asked right now to dinner
i'm married you oh you finished in here
you are a wild then
i remember i was a demon back then
that's not too much that is too much
risk oh gosh
yeah and then i was like you don't want
me buying the plan b she's like no i
already got one
oh my gosh yeah i bet you she had a
whole rotation of guys she did that with
she already had them like there
uh
she said she was gonna take care of it
so i guess she took care of her took her
word for it was she over 150
are you talking about the statistic that
statistic about if one weighs a certain
amount it won't work the contraceptive
won't work yeah like it doesn't work
over a certain weight but no the um the
plan b only works if you're under a
certain weight
i don't know i've hooked up with some
girls that are like 175 180 and they
worked for them
you might
be careful man wow you think i have a
little sun out there in the world you
might you're just nuts
and [ __ ]
bro
oh
basketball team
let's start a little basketball team
after half the time i wore the rubber
half the time i didn't sometimes i
pulled out not many times but i most uh
it's either i netted or i put all right
it was wearing the condom
oh my god
you be careful you are gonna one of
those i got myself tested though i'm
clean i'm glad i'm clean
yeah well i'm not even
like in stds i i i think i would imagine
a lot are curable you can at least take
medicine or whatever but the kid is
different yeah that bad
so pearl do you have a do you have a son
do you have a son or do you have a
daughter no
none
oh my gosh i've been very careful i do
not mess with i could just see your
little daughter out there a little
ginger hair and then playing volleyball
with you
well
i'd like to have one someday actually i
want all boys
and i want to have yeah because hear me
out
make sure they don't turn them into
simps don't turn them into simps i i
need five boys and i'm gonna have them
all at the same time so two sets of
twins and then another and then they're
just gonna be starting five on the
basketball team that's my dream oh my
god that way if um if there's like let's
say they have a bad coach i won't have
to deal with that because
what i can do is i can just teach them
the plays myself
and like what are you gonna do get rid
of the starting five like clearly
they're going to be tall i'm six foot
i'm trying to start five
i hope to marry someone taller that's
the dream anyway
um
so yeah like that
i see no holes and i will let them know
that my love for them is going to be
determined
by how well they play that week
so if they want like an extra allowance
or something how many buckets did you
score
probably like 20 20 21 25 26 points 30
points yeah and but whoever scored the
least
what you're going to bench them you're
going to
be the mom i'm just going to like love
them less you know what i mean wow
that's messed up yeah
yeah
yeah that's not that's how um that's how
the davis clan is going to be
the davis clinton wow oh wait not davis
it'll be a different last name it'll be
the fat five the modern the monarch all
i know is d1 and i see no flaws no flaws
well you also got to tell them hey it's
okay to go overseas and play profession
because a lot of overseas contracts are
actually
sometimes more wealthier than nba
contracts
oh yeah
it's you can make a lot as a guy not as
a girl girls
yeah no offense but
y'all y'all girls are tripping when you
guys grow on like a million dollar
contracts and you girls are missing
layups can't even dunk
airballing threes i've seen them in wnba
no i don't
i think it's unfortunate i i in my heart
of hearts like if i could do anything
the rest of my life i would play sports
i wish to god i wish there was
opportunity for women but you can't like
we're not good enough to get make that
much money sorry
i think one of the main sports that guys
like watching women is volleyball games
because the in the sand cause
little tight little booty shorts and
like
honestly a lot of those women have
really good bodies they really do i will
give that compliment they're really in
shape
have you played in the sand have you
played in the sand this [ __ ] is tough
i'm not as good at it it's uh my
position
isn't very it doesn't transfer very well
to sand
um like usually liberos or outsides and
setters do well in sand but middles
not so much
damn
you already want a freaking starting
five and it's not even fair
um
yeah
i mean i'm half kidding when i tell that
story i do want like boys the fact that
you're half not kidding is what's crazy
look at i see no flaws in this plan none
it's gonna be
hey chad hey brad hey hey tommy hey
billy hey tyrone
i just i don't really want girls i
because i just i don't think i can watch
women's sports i want my kids to be in
sports and i just don't think i can
watch women's sports i like watching
women's mma fighters like i like
watching the ufc women's mma i'm a huge
fan of like rose and i'm a eunice if you
know her
doug rose she goes by thug rose she's a
little like 135 125 pound white girl but
she can fight she can scrap and then
there's like other women like amanda
nunez like uh chris cyborg
a whole bunch of women that are actually
really good at fighting but
ronda rousey i really wasn't into her i
was just attracted to her that was it
but ronda rousey i didn't know i'm
attractive no
well that's because you're not a dude
but yeah well i just
i don't know she kind of scares me
a little bit
a lot of the time she puts on that act
though she puts that act on the face of
a mean face oh i'm sure wait okay i have
a super chat
thank you so much for the donation guys
i've been struggling lately so i really
appreciate every donation that you guys
send me so much
on a first date a guy drove me to trader
joe's and asked me to pick out two
frozen dinners we went to his place and
he asked me to heat them up in the
microwave i asked to go home
nice that's a bold move a microwave
daenerys what do you think of that
one yeah he got he got something to eat
in his belly and he got he
he got the other stuff
you think she slept with him
maybe sort of sounds like it's like
they're very comfortable with each other
oh really it sounds like it sounded to
me like
they did not sleep together because she
like wanted to go home do you want
ubereats and then they take me home
crazy dating story i had six women in a
rotation when i was single all of them
were aware of each other now i'm married
to one who had the greatest value in my
life
what is the most girls you've juggled in
a rotation
me
yeah
i think about like
about five or six
did you see all of them like every week
not every week no it was spontaneous
from time to time sometimes it was
repetitive sometimes of the pattern but
did they know about each other
no
no okay so where did they think you were
when they wouldn't hear from you uh
either either work or school
or stuff with my family
um which is all legitimate but i wasn't
completely like i wasn't bullshitting
about that i just didn't tell them about
each other
did um yeah but they didn't have like
they couldn't put two and two together
no
no
no
what i did was i specifically chose a
girl because the way it works where i
live it's like
in california there's like a couple
cities close to me so they're all within
a few minutes here and there so i would
pick a girl from each different city
demographic and that's what i would do
and like within like
have you ever had them find out about
each other
um i think once i think once so i can't
remember correctly
i think once but it it just didn't turn
awkward that was a good thing it just
didn't it didn't get awkward or nothing
did did you do you make them think
you're looking for a relationship or do
you just tell them from the jump that no
like this is i'm just trying to
i usually approach it honestly with that
and i'll say either this is the way i
look at it is hey
at first it's about dating and having
fun and then if it blossoms into a
relationship then that that'll happen
but i don't like to let it happen
forcefully if it if it happens and we
show each other the traits for it to
become a relationship i think that's the
best way to go about it for my
experience
um if either a woman when she hears that
out front she's like
i want to just a direct answer then i'll
be like no all right well on the door
hit you on the way out
i respect you not wanting to waste your
time if that's what you're thinking but
i'm not wasting your time by me being
honest like that though that's the way i
look at it if it blossoms it blossoms
what i've noticed is i think men are
actually quite honest in what they're
looking for women just don't listen and
then get mad later would you agree with
that or disagree
um
i would say 50 50 on that women i do
they do listen but they want to listen
to what they want to hear sometimes is
my thing yeah yeah so it's not that they
don't listen half the time half the time
they might be on their mission it might
be on their age demographic
it might be something like that but you
were saying
well i was in that case so if you said
i'm not looking for anything like what
you just said that same thing but then
you add but i really like you and like i
really enjoy spending time with you they
would just hear the second part
oh you mean like they focus just on like
a certain part of the sentence and they
kind of like oh he likes me likes me and
i was like yeah i didn't say that like
that but yeah sure let's go with it yeah
no but i uh what i would do is also
it depends on the style of like
like if she meets my parents then it's
serious
if she meets my parents it's serious and
if if i start talking about our more
serious stuff like we we start learning
about more serious stuff behind our
walls
that's when you know it gets serious too
do you know what actually that just
reminded me of a crazy dating story from
a friend of mine this didn't happen to
me but this is a girl i knew in
milwaukee
and oh my gosh
she
this guy like
took her on this
like she just met him like i don't know
a week or two ago i forgot how they met
maybe a dating app or something
but he introduced her to his whole
family and like brought her on this like
boat like this cruise ship thing and it
was very nice and expensive with the
family and it was like a dinner i guess
it was in downtown milwaukee i'm
probably butchering it because this was
a couple years ago
but
i guess she finds out later that he does
that with like every girl like he would
just like
does he do it quickly
i i did did he introduce did he
introduce his family to her quickly like
on what like the second date or
something gosh i don't know
um
i don't remember but i i think it was
pretty quick but i think she took that
as like
me yeah and he just
like all the the family just knew that
he would have a new girl every like
three weeks or something or two weeks
this guy wasn't wasting time
no
but he wasn't trying to date her it was
just like uh
just trying to impress her like or
something no i think he was just trying
to make her comfortable so she'd sleep
with him and i think she did so i guess
it worked
can i tell you something because um yeah
and a previous relationship i had this
probably was like the most toxic one
when it came to like the outcome results
of the ending of it but
in the second date
um
she met my parents unintentionally like
because i guess the first date well i
had technically got her number at the
gym because i used to go to the 24-hour
fitness gym a lot
um
that one over there and then
i got her number gave her some cheesy
compliment
and uh
they it worked and then they got her
number and
uh at the time i believe she was i was
20 21 she was about 29 gonna be 30.
um so she was a little bit older
um
but
i got her number and then i ended up
we ended up having a first date later
we ended up going to like some i don't
know like ihop or something
and it was just simple and then we just
the first date that we start making out
um
mackin like crazy in public and in the
car but
the second date happens and then she we
met at like uh
this record store like like sell like
old school records and like music and
stuff in the mall
and
we we go we hang out we're talking about
each other and she's i'm telling her
like oh i have a sister who's deaf and i
know sign language and she works with
like special needs kids
and then i was like oh i have a little
dog too and then
she kind of wasn't believing me because
she didn't trust a lot of men but then
once i like
showed her like oh i am who i am what i
was saying i was
she kind of was like oh like
she literally what she did was she kind
of like
she got me she pulled me in and like oh
she was making like she was like
she was like the aggressive one right
there making out with me in the back of
the house
and she was kind of like thrusting
herself at me
like with the clothes
but she was kind of like it was kind of
like when a dog is humping a dog
but she was the one front humping me
like
and it was like interesting and then all
of a sudden as we're gonna leave my
parents walk and they come in from
whatever i think they came from like a
date or something
my dad took my mom out
and my it wasn't my plans for her to
meet my parents yet if i would have
chosen it i would have introduced it to
my parents
later later
but they showed up and they're just glad
that like it's like oh like they were
smiling because it's like uh
they're happy that i like i had a girl
because like i never really introduced
my girls to to my parents
um if it was that serious it went that
seriously i rarely ever introduced him
it was like one or two other times where
i introduced a girlfriend to my parents
and i think this was like the the second
or third girl that
met my parents but it was unintentional
and it was just like
i just said in the background i was like
i can't believe she just met the parents
like that
and like kind of an accident you didn't
did she think it was serious then after
that because she met your parents
i think i think in her head yeah like i
think in her head she started playing
like a script in her head like a movie
or something
and
i mean i went along with it it was cool
she she was a single mom though she had
a kid
um but i was young at that time like i
said i was like 20 21
like 20 years
that was your demon days right
right
right i was a fiend i was a fiend did i
miss something
that was a fiend yeah like and it was
when marcus is crazy yeah
i'm not that crazy i'm honestly not i'm
not
a lot of the girls they did they went
crazy on like they were the crazy ones a
lot of the girls
look at it goes both ways oh
don't do me like that don't do me like
that pearl no i'm saying like like
they're saying you're crazy i'm saying
girls are crazy too
yeah i'm sure
some of you good things too
don't get me wrong sometimes maybe i
didn't vet the girl the long the long
way sometimes like
you know because there's a there was a
it's just in these small cities and
these small towns everybody knows each
other even more you know and you start
hearing like when oh this girl did this
at the party but she was with me over
here and
stuff like that it travels around
quickly and especially in social media
oh my gosh i had a conversation with a
girl the other day when
basically
she she did stuff with two guys on the
men's team and i was like you don't
think they're gonna find out they're on
the same team and she's like oh no guys
don't talk like that i'm like i think
they do
am i maybe maybe they don't i don't know
but yeah
i have another crazy story too real
quick
okay um i'm gonna let i'm gonna let some
of the new people talk but then if you
want to tell it after i'd be done
hi welcome to the stream is that torsion
hello pearl
my titties are just like popping i
didn't know you were alive i was live
and i was like oh [ __ ] okay i'm gonna
end my stream and i came over here
how are you
i'm good how are you
i'm good how is everybody
we got man's in the house
doing great
what's up jay
what's up brother how are you doing
marsha do you have a crazy dating story
here no
uh
of course
okay you you were in the chat next so
tell me tell me your crazy dating story
so i just
you're the only one that knows mine
because i told you last time i was with
you
name the
[ __ ]
what probably wasn't that crazy to me no
you're right it probably wasn't to you
but
my identity was stolen
that's why oh yeah you win go on come on
so uh i work in like the nightlife
industry no i'm not a stripper but
um i was kind of seeing
dating this dude that was he
he was the guy that would get like
seven percent off of every liquor sale
because he would do events there i don't
really know what that's called but he
did well he was like
an artist manager
for the club okay i don't know if that
made
i don't know he did well we were in
tulum what's new
i'm kidding no like
he was like let's go to tulum and i was
like okay never been to mexico don't
have a passport he's like we'll get you
one whatever and so i went to go
get my i know
sorry oh it gets so bad
i went to the cvs [ __ ]
i always run into midgets like real life
midgets not just somebody who's short
i'm talking [ __ ] and he gets on a
stool i'm already like great this
photo's gonna look real good real good
it came out to be one of my best photos
i've ever taken it was great but um did
you buy that ninja happy meal
no but i've gone to him ever since i'm
like can you do my instagram photos i'm
just kidding
anyways so i get all the stuff to get a
passport if you guys didn't know if you
need a passport in literally 24 hours
what you can do is hire an agency that
will have you submit all the documents
and then they get it over to you in 24
hours it's very expensive but it is way
i don't know
some people know that you can do it in
like two weeks but i know people that
have lost their passports like
in the destination they are so that's
how you get one so then um obviously i
had my social security card and birth
certificate
and then
a couple
months later
we broke up he still had my documents
which sounds crazy i get it it does
but
you know i trusted him i was like what
what's he gonna do with it
then i googled his ass
and then i found out he was arrested for
fraud and all this [ __ ] like whatever
you never you never googled him while
you were dating
uh no i take people's word i worked as a
pi so even now like i take people's word
for whatever they say i don't like go
i could easily run a background check on
something i'm not going to do that it's
stupid what's the point like let people
be you should not get your identity
stolen well that was my fault
i would have saved you she went to
mexico and she should have drugged you
with the cartel
first of all
too soon okay so under identity fraud i
didn't know that you have to fill out
all these forms every year just for it
it's not even like close your credit
cards anyway so homie pulled out a house
he was paying it my credit was great i
was like you know what
i get it
i [ __ ] get it he sold it to somebody
sold my identity to somebody that
couldn't uh either they were an
immigrant whatever zero judgment homie
was paying
six months down the line homie stopped
paying and then
oh my god he took out like uh you know
those credit cards you can get at stores
like a macy's card he pulled those out
i'm so against those i'm very uh frugal
with money i just like crazy with it he
pulled out a car note
didn't have insurance gotten an accident
like a six-car pile up something
that's actually what got me into pi
because apparently even when you have
their address in their name you cannot
press charges
like the irs can so i still have this
like identity fraud on my account
all because of a [ __ ] tulum trip
that should be merch
that's the craziest yeah
what about you
no i can't i see you know it though
can you remind me like give me a little
it was it wasn't that crazy but it was
it was the guy that i dated for like
barely
like i dated i dated him before i found
him
i know what about you jay
jay takishi takeshi
j takeshi
okay that's close i'll give it that oh
i'm gonna let me sound it out hold on i
have jaw problems
to cash to keshie
oh like takashi
yes but don't ever bring up no i know
but it
rolls off the tongue
yeah [ __ ] that man he's a [ __ ] rat
i remember pearl saying that you said in
a video you said you don't mind me and
then i was like okay i'm gonna use some
cheese
okay i'm a snitcher if i got out of jail
time i'm not like but i'm not tough i
wouldn't do well in prison like if i if
i really i would snitch oh i do so well
i would do terrible
i'd pee on myself because nobody wants
to [ __ ] with the girl that you don't
need yourself
no but you shouldn't
i'm going to hook up with the biggest
girl there
there you go
i don't like i don't like girls i can't
do that i mean the meanies are pearl but
when push comes to shove and you're
trying to survive
i'm gonna be gay for a bit yeah
i
no i don't want to i'd be like get away
you're not cute
you're going to get your ass beat no i'm
going to snitch and get out of jail it's
like did i stutter no but like you sh
the way that well we shouldn't go into
takashi's thing but if you be [ __ ]
around with
different groups and then talk [ __ ]
about other groups
and then snitch you're snitching on more
people than you even know like it's not
just
the guy that sold you weed you know or
whatever it's like big deal like they'll
kill you while you're in jail but he's
still alive
right
when did this turn into the first 48
people don't want to [ __ ] with him dude
he's a [ __ ] snitch but he's alive and
he's still making music like i don't
know i'd rather be killed at that point
i don't want to say it but he will be
attacked at one point because torsion
is correct because trust me there was a
whole stream of guys that talked about
this and they're actually right they are
everywhere even if you don't even in
wyoming and you might not believe it but
they're everywhere they're watching they
just don't show themselves i'm too
paranoid
yeah that's it it's on one person too
you [ __ ] with the wrong person so it's
yep i don't know i'm too agreeable in
nature i would probably say [ __ ] to the
wrong person
forget that i did t.i snitched but
everyone's silent i don't know anything
about that ti's he probably paid them
off
yeah yeah he probably paid them all
here's the money he has none
he's got a different vibe to him that i
don't know if i've never met takashi but
t.i is like that quiet guy that just
sips pineapple juice in the club while
everybody else is popping bottles on his
name and you're just like why are you
sober and why are you facing the door
you know okay okay okay
okay
jay what is your crazy dating
personality
crazy dating story
okay yeah
oh
okay i got too many to count what'd she
look like
was she curious
no no no she was cute she was cute
please believe i like pretty cute girls
especially if they have like cute
exterior faces she was particularly she
like okay naughty christian girls so
we'll just get into that bag and you
don't expect there to be off the wall
crazy
um
so
yeah yeah i didn't i didn't expect that
at least at least the first time anytime
somebody claims to be a christian girl
when i was like younger like around 17.
yeah a little bit a little bit more
naive
i'm like okay so don't okay don't assume
you're gonna go into the gusto jaden
this you know treat her like a normal
girl and just you know
yeah
exactly i'm like okay
and then
after first the first few minutes after
we um i guess after we leave the
bookstore because you know she got me a
present for my birthday which is rare in
itself and you know i thanked her she
thought i said that she wanted to give
me a bj literally in a freaking car and
i'm like okay
and that literally just took me back and
i'm just like okay and and i thought so
much from like
when the
like did i flip her switch
or
or was she just was she just wet the
whole time and i'm just like i'm gonna
guess either or at this point because
i'm like okay so
we we just
so she had braces at this time
braces oh no yes
i think i know where this
is i'm telling you it's like 40 year old
virgin
i just think no no no you know what
pierced
yeah exactly but but the thing is
surprisingly i was that's the one thing
i was afraid of and i was like okay if
it happens
there's a hospital like two minutes away
from your album oh my god she better
turn into an eel
yes you know you know
so yeah so she so she was going in slow
so i was like just whatever you do jay
whatever you do
don't grab it by your head i know you
have this thing where you only kind of
grab girls by their head you know
because they like kind of because they
kind of like because she particularly
was one of the girls that liked it rough
and i'm like no you have braces on so
i'm not even going to attempt to do that
so
so it i felt the metal touched me but it
didn't pierce me and i was just and all
i can say is that's enough i think yeah
yeah it's like thank mother freaking god
because i was afraid of her piercing me
and then i literally okay here's the
funny part
i literally roll out the car
the front door
after she's done
i literally look i have half of my pants
on but it's nighttime it's night time
thank goodness this is like actually the
only weird time that i actually look
goofy i rolled out the i wrote out the
car door
i literally go to my my belt is like
halfway in between my pants
then i have to go freaking get my pants
up i'm like okay you gotta okay you
gotta lock up because like
they patrol around the um outside of the
mall area and it's like a complex but
it's in an area where it's like very
secluded so i just had to hurry up and
then you couldn't put them
no on no because i no no only because
she spilled something on me gotcha okay
wait
she spilled something on you yeah i i
was lost i was like who pulls their
pants up outside you could be a sex
offender in this day
so
okay so so basically she had like a
freaking slushie that she had in there
and i told her to move it if she was
going to you know say she's going to go
down on me because if she knocks it over
me then it was going to spill on my
jeans and it spilled on my goddamn jeans
for a moment i thought she was slurping
on her slushie while she was sucking you
know i was like what
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
so
so okay okay let me just i just want to
make sure i understand
so she was giving you a [ __ ] in the
car
that she knocked over
and then and then there was
you she almost caught you with their
braces but she didn't she graced yeah
she did
and then she knocked over the [ __ ]
something like this
wasn't it was it on your did it was it
on your d like
like all right
yes oh so it got everywhere
now tell me was this mid or were you
done like
this is like okay this is going like
after like letter sheep and she knocked
it over i was like
what the [ __ ] oh
it was one of god ones
but no no i didn't okay so there's one
thing i didn't want to hate her after it
i'm like
jay
what did you yes
like i i did get upset a little bit but
i was like don't be angry
uh it's okay i was like oh it's okay so
don't worry you're fine yeah i'll i'll
watch this when i get home and thank
goodness these were black pants no white
pants then i gotta get it i gotta throw
these bastards away and get some new
ones but um i think the really craziest
one is when um
we literally uh
uh
exhibition play more so
she wanted to know what it was like to
have sex in the woods
and um
cold
[Music]
spot where me and my boys go hiking
because i know that area enough and i
know i know what animals are around and
there's no animals particularly in this
area
this is the christian girl the slurpee
slurpee [ __ ] same okay yeah slurpee
girl
so yeah and um
and uh she
she literally jumped when she heard
something crawl on the tree and then she
and then she rolls over
and then i catch her i'm like
uh i'm not letting i am not letting you
freaking do it do do another freaking 40
year old virgin trick that's just not
happening we're not going through the
same thing we did last time i'm at this
point i'm thinking you guys are for
playing duck dynasty or some [ __ ]
hey listen it was
a little bit every once in a while but
she but she was you guys were laying
down in the woods oh my god staying up
standing up oh okay okay okay i'm doing
the work are you kidding me
yeah it's true a lot of women like fish
i'm going to work and plus i kind of
kind of have a pride thing so i was like
okay so i might as well j just finish
out you'll be okay just um like spread
it out to the end and uh thank goodness
i made her like climax like three times
before i at least got mine off so it was
it was a weird experience because i'm
like i am never having sex in the court
again why the hell would i ever do this
[ __ ] again the only reason why
i said yes is because i'm new to it but
yeah yeah guys turtles tend to go back
in their shell when it's too cold
i just yeah sometimes
sometimes
no you must have you must have been hard
as trigonometry you must have been hard
as pre-calculus
oh okay so so for that so so for that
day that we did do it i actually did get
done with the swim beat so i actually
was building up adrenaline after that
so
so this is a lot of work
so what the worst date
you said this year actually that that
one's that one's probably the probably
the worst one because people be [ __ ]
like that right away
oh yeah people will [ __ ] with jack that
was our that was our fifth table that we
did that that was the thing
that we did that
yeah not the first one no the first one
was when i told you girl i'm just like
what
i'm so confused how you ended up on
another country torsha like how did you
end up across state lines in the cross
did you go through
you said you had a story over mexico
right you ended up in mexico with that
guy
for the first date
so i'm still wondering first date
oh he pulled my identity
oh
yeah i thought you said you ended up
over there i was like how do you go from
america to go to loom and it was great
it was was it worth it was it worth it
no
yeah kind of actually
yeah because now
i can sue eventually if i can figure out
how
okay marcus do you want to tell
jay i think
jay are you is it a or j i don't know aj
hey everyone how you doing i don't know
if a stood for something i don't know
um
okay what's your craziest dating story
let's
hear it i guess
the one that comes to mind with me is
i'm a really extroverted person so i'm
pretty easy to talk to and i i just
moved to a new area and i met this girl
and
uh it was kind of like in the middle of
nowhere in in pennsylvania so
whatever yeah and i went out to put this
chick and we met at this restaurant
first first of all she was like 30
pounds heavier than a picture on
on the dating app right so i'm like ah
well i'm
i'm hungry so i'll just eat you know and
uh so we're talking and people tend to
open up and we're having a conversation
and then she starts talking about her ex
and then how she had this miscarriage
and sorry what's that no no keep going
it's getting worse
and then she just starts talking about
like how she had this miscarriage and
how her ex didn't stay and just go and
i'm like
what the hell i mean i understand that
i'm easy to talk to you but like i'm not
your counselor you know what i'm saying
so i'm like eating my food
and then
she's just her whole life story which in
the last like couple years before she
was not good so imagine
a date of just this comedy of errors and
crazy craziness and i'm like okay
that's great and it's like are we gonna
go out again i'm like
what no
no that's cool you know so i don't think
talking about your crazy ex let's talk
to you and your miscarriage is good for
state uh
no it would be fun to hang out and meet
her i mean she seems like a crazy person
she do you have her number we should get
on the podium
[Laughter]
this batch is one of those
i like my people
there was another girl that that i had
hung out with this is like college this
is like senior
college and our first date went really
really well
and the second date was like all right
well it's time to get down you know
because we haven't really messed around
or anything you know so we go to this
restaurant this nice place and where
everything and she hands me this
pamphlet and it says like
hi you know i have herpes this is what
you should know about herpes and i'm
like what
at least
that was the thing i mean i kind of
ghosted her after that because i'm not
messing with anyone who has herpes but i
respect the fact that that she's upfront
about it so
can i
give you some advice
that you don't know uh
uh i don't need any deity why'd you
gotta ghost her ass when she was at
least up front with you come on
because okay
there's dating sets for people who have
that stuff right you shouldn't be on a
regular dating site like when we on the
first date
it's like you should let a person know
that
type of things up front because the
first date went really well we went to
karaoke we're like doing uh duets and
stuff like it was our birthdays were a
day
apart we were like vibing a pretty good
so you you really liked her and then she
did it early though
and what i'm saying is like
and then she was mad at me
i go to their app it was late later on
because i was like ah yeah she got mad
because like i wasn't about to kind of
get get get down and dirty you know what
i'm saying so she left and then tried to
call me lately later and was like well i
understand why you were upset i'll give
you another chance
and i'm like what i know okay she's
[ __ ] nuts like yeah
yeah
i don't i don't think
i don't think it's ghosting if you met
them did you meet her online or did you
know her
uh it was just meeting online
and then i just
just just stopped talking to her over
time i mean at least in that situation
she probably knows why he ghosted so
then it's not that bad but i just think
if it's if it's two dates or less i
don't think it's ghosting you barely
know them you met him twice
off of online i don't know i've never
done that [ __ ] so i'm like i don't know
i don't know well but the thing is
ghosting see is this
there's a word for ghosting now like
ghosting is a relatively new word but
people have done it like i have female
friends that have ghosted guys for like
a reason you know what i'm saying like
in college yeah but girls are usually
looking to disqualify you
depending on what it is then but now now
that dating is so casual people are
dating so many people at once it's like
is it really worth
this small kind of micro
confrontation to just get get rid of a
person like dude i just know like i
don't want to talk to you i don't want
to deal with this
dude
i don't know
i have one i'm on your side aj i'm on
the other side i respect you
two dates or less you barely knew her i
don't know
yeah like i guess i can't really say
yeah i respect aj i respect aj for
having dick discipline because he
thought about his health over his dick
well no i'm not saying that that was
wrong but i'm just saying like i'm
saying is that people
people so like pearl if if i just
met you let's say that like we went out
twice or whatever or we're talk talking
and texting because people even say stop
texting if we've never met that that's
ghosting and i'm
if if we just met and you're like saying
you're not judging that
that you shouldn't be able to the ghost
it means that that person thinks that
you owe them something and if and that's
i agree with you
i think
if you if you never slept with her you
barely know her like
no i don't i don't think two dates from
a dating app no you could go sir i'm not
yeah i don't know i just feel like our
lack in empathy
i just feel like a simple hey you know
i'm just not cool with that like
good luck like just as simple that would
have been like cool but you mean you
mean being more courteous
yeah just a little bit yeah i get that
though i get the i get you
i could understand what you're saying
yeah but like if she comes at you with
some [ __ ] like block her take me at my
herpes now take me away i just think
that we're getting too easily disposable
that's what i think
i think it's a nice like thing to do but
i don't think you're owed an explanation
after two dates like you barely know
each other
you meant she wrote me like a
handwritten note you don't know anybody
anything
up to you if you want to do that or not
i got a handwritten note and snail mail
at my in my mailbox like she mailed me
like literally
and wrote a note like put a stamp on and
mail the sorry i don't mean a well it
nailed it to my house
yeah i just really thought well you hit
it off and i'm like what is going on you
know did you go on more than two dates
be honest
we went out we went out out twice but we
were like texting and talking and on the
phone and stuff for like
a month and a half maybe yeah
i knew that was cool
i feel like okay
because girls can fall in love or
create this version of you that doesn't
exist pretty quickly
so
yeah but that's why you'd be up front
because she even said i thought we were
on the same page and our last phone
conversation and i said yeah we were
never on the space because when we first
met you knew you had herpes and i didn't
so we were not on that oh no that's the
thing i thought she told you right away
no did she did you kiss her second did
you kiss her before she told you
oh
wait wait okay first of all guys let's
not be ignorant okay we know that it's
treated okay but i wouldn't want to date
anybody with it so i can understand why
somebody doesn't want to but just to be
respectful for people that do have it
like it's treated you don't have to
contract it
but what i'm saying though
i
you were saying no go ahead
but here's the thing is this
and
is
um
if there is
a permanent disease right so like
it's because i've thought about this in
multiple like scenarios
imagine that you're like a person that's
a person that's had to make a decision
or that had like a promotion that they
were going to move away for or had to
make a big decision and they didn't make
it because of you right that's pressure
on the related relationship to work
because then that person goes oh well
pearl i could have got a job at google
in san francisco but i stayed here for
you so you need to block imagine if
you're that person that's that it's with
a person that has herpes or whatever
when you get it or whatever that you you
might feel a little bit trapped to stay
with that person because what the hell
are you gonna do on the open market with
herpes yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying like
like that's why
sorry go ahead
so yeah i just i i just ninja man
vanished out of that straight up smoke
bomb
that was it you know i just i think that
the reason this girl contracted it was
either from a guy that didn't tell her
you know something happened whether it
was a girl he hooked up with him maybe
he didn't know but
she did the right thing by telling you a
simple just you know i'm just not
comfortable doing that would have just
would give her the honesty a lot of
people in the rp want to say don't give
her honesty and i get that
but
she could move the next way into an app
that's
like like you said it's just for people
with herpes you know but maybe she's
like
doesn't even know that exists women
don't think in like um
well i don't want to say women don't but
i just think that maybe it was like a
new thing and
you know it's hurtful
unfortunate
because i have a friend of mine from
college she got married in high school
and then she was with her husband for
15 years and then got divorced the first
guy she slept with after
the first guy she slept with after she
got divorced she got herpes from
so the second guy she ever slept with
gave her herpes like damn i'm just a
[ __ ]
hypogamy doesn't care i was going to say
because because there's a lot of stds
that are dormant and they're they
hibernate yeah they don't pop up until
years later so that's a little help
class for people that are listening in
the chat yeah just because you don't get
just just because you don't get it now
doesn't mean you won't get it later yeah
and like like that x that i told you
about pearl earlier the the toxic one
she didn't she told me this is after we
had sex and i had gone down on her she
had said she had a what's that thing
that girls get down there is it
chlamydia or gonorrhea
it's it's girls and guys get get get
yeah and gone okay
the one that's like with the based on
the discharge like for women down there
what kind of discharge i used to want to
be a gynecologist
oh
like the baby doctor but it involved
like female reproductive yeah uh to be
honest the only thing i remember about
gonorrhea is tracker track is like the
the i don't know the uti is it the
utility the bacteria so it's green
that's just all i know with that and
then chlamydia
lap and antibiotics that's all i know
men and women have discharged from
gonorrhea oh okay yeah i know i can't
remember which one she had but i i went
after she told me we were like eating in
a public place
and i told her to be honest with us
because i was honest with her about
things we were opening up to each other
and she told me she dropped me that bomb
and it's like after we were like you
know physical and intimate and stuff
like
somebody went down on her
we went down on each other but you know
did you get checked
out back then yeah yeah i did
gonorrhea
no i didn't get it no no i was clean i
was clear
okay but
but she obviously she had told me like
she told me like oh don't worry like
i've gone to the doctor and they kind of
say it's on hibernation or some [ __ ] all
like
no
but yeah that's something yeah like i
gave her a chance after we did it for a
bit after but it just it wasn't the same
just because stuff didn't work out
towards the end jay knows about her
story but those are one of the things
that she dropped the bomb on me and i
was just like you expect me to be honest
with you but you can't be honest with me
about certain things i think that's
where people get lost in translation of
communication and stuff yeah it's
embarrassing stuff too i can only
imagine
yeah that's not i'd imagine that's the
double-edged sword because if you're
dating you don't want every like person
to know you have that
like you don't want to just be telling
everyone like that's private but at the
same time someone you're dating should
know that well if you're physical with
i'm with you i'm in agreement i just met
like i was thinking about aj's situation
where it was before they were physical i
no that's that's disgusting
yeah
i was on another date with a girl once
and uh we've gone out like three times
and i don't get physical in the first
like date or two i'll kiss and all but i
don't sleep with a person yeah i know
pretty well and this girl like um
she was pretty cool and but then the
fourth day we went to hang out
with her friends right and
she completely changed it it was a bad
day anyways because i had met her at it
at a at a at a bar or like this
distillery that
was supposed to eat i hadn't eaten all
day i drove far it closed so we're out
with her friends and i'm like i need to
eat you know i'm a big guy i need to eat
so her friends wanted to go everywhere
but a rather restaurant and one of them
had a dog anyways so honestly
at any other restaurants because you
can't bring in the restaurants right so
we up at this top place and look i'm 6'3
i'm 240. like i need food i'm not going
tapas is not enough for me unless i
spend a lot of cash right so whatever so
she was talk like her attitude totally
changed like she was talking all this
[ __ ] to me
in front of her friends it was really
really really really odd right
and
her friends were just like i was the
only guy and they were on this weird
like we need to
talk [ __ ] about men and say ridic
things yeah
it sounds like she's trying to use you
as a trick bro it sounds like she was
trying to use it as a trick to pay for
her friends
no
so
so what happened was
an argument and it ended up ending and
her go looking at at me and being like
because it was
the same and you guys can tell i'm loud
as [ __ ] so i don't care
she's like you're on your way to a
friend zone buddy right
like bye
she said bing bong
yeah
they got up and went to the bad bathroom
i paid for my ticket and i left
good job
so
i'm in the uber and my phone starts
blowing up it's her i block blocked her
uh a phone number from san diego which
is her friend who was loud starts
calling me i knew it was her friend
blocked it i look
on facebook where she was where are you
uh i thought we had something i really
liked you ew
instagram dude that's [ __ ] nuts
she wanted to use it as a game bro like
a pure imp that's what she's trying to
use you ass
no those are man
okay guys i'm out of here have a good
rest of your stream pearl bye yeah all
right
be careful bye
guys sam sam what is your crazy dating
story
yeah your prayer can you hear me yeah i
can hear you oh it's going to be a good
one you're more of a sin sir if nothing
else
same story
i was having some story okay i was
moving out there 29 years when i was 21
and it was um quite interesting
so um back then i was um
senior in college um went to a party
and met this girl she looked very nice
um she was on lithuanian
one of the next day um and i going back
to her place um nothing happened we'll
just talk but the next night
went over and we're talking and
it's like um she wanted to do something
with me and i was just like
i'd have anything with me um let me go
back and i'll come back and just like no
i'll do um don't take me tomorrow
you're good um
she went ahead did that and then the
next day you just look
[ __ ] no i'm not taking anything um
yeah
that was um quite interesting somehow we
got over all of that stuff um
probably just because it was hot and
good and bad to be honest with you
but
yeah so we did it for a while even mad
like her whole family even that was way
younger than her
that was quite interesting um
anyway um and this is not probably more
for you aj at the end of the story
but um that one from away eventually
she cheated on me um that didn't work
out
that was the end of that um
i ended up going to grad school home
i was done afterwards i hit it up and we
just like
had such a couple times left to that um
but anyway um so this is more for you aj
as i was saying from this
so down the line um don't that have a
new girlfriend um who i really like
trying to go for with and i was just
like
i should probably get tested just make
sure i'm good um so i do go get tested
and i found out that i do have herpes um
in my case i've never had any symptoms
whatsoever just more of
[ __ ] i'm so young i'm 25 right now so
just like
well yeah um so that was the first sort
of like big reflect i got tested again
that came back negative
and got that star third time and i came
back positive
and i'm here with no sentence whatever
i'm just like trying to go through that
[ __ ]
and so pretty much um
yes there are lots of stds out there um
but when it comes to herpes there
isn't really a lot of research and serve
around that even now the testing is just
the one process stuff
and with the cdc there is there's going
to be a new test that's going to be
coming
relatively soon um that's another gear
from that that should be a two tips a
two step cases but the way on prairie
peace book is that um you get up but
certain times when you get that um you
take like value trucking stuff to like
suppress it and it goes away um the only
major like life service if let's say
a female hasn't just given birth it can
affect your baby um
it's like the major thing for that but
yeah um so anyway that's sort of the
step i was in for a long time um
i finally told my current girlfriend all
of this last night actually
and she was actually very cool about it
so just like um thanks for telling me oh
it's not something that's gonna stop
putting me together um this is like when
they made you think so we could so
just like giving some advice but yeah
that should happen so just
who you're sleeping if you didn't know
that i'm sure it can happen are you
sorry i know a
that's really unfortunate i'm sorry to
hear that man i mean well i mean i'm
sorry
yeah i guess that's all we can say is
we're sorry but i'm just glad that
you're making it work you know what i
mean
you know you sound good i mean
i don't it's it's kind of crazy for all
of us like we're so sorry but i mean i'm
just you sound like like you're okay and
that's that means more than anything
else you know
no it happens i'm just saying so i mean
with the whole girl thing it's
definitely good that she took you ahead
of time but it took a lot of her to tell
you that just because even with me i was
just like how the hell am i going to
tell my current girlfriend this it's
pretty much going to be over for me oh
so it was already you didn't know until
you'd already started dating no we
started dating but we haven't done
anything and then i've found out um that
that had that so i just didn't do
anything with her i was just like
let me make sure i'm good till we talk
about this so literally having had sex
with her for the last three months just
because i was trying to make sure i'm
good
that in my case the issue was like we
were we were
that date was the date that we were
gonna you know
yeah and then she during at dinner she
brought out the flyers she made and the
information information and then when we
were like back at my we went back to my
house and i'm trying to you you don't
drop the bomb on someone at in a
restaurant like that and then we go
back to my house
and she's trying to like fool around and
then she kind of saw that i was like ah
and then all of a sudden she's mad at me
and acting like like it's my problem
problem and then well and then all of a
sudden the aggression starts well you
know i'm not my body's not a toxic waste
dump it but you're insinuating and i
hadn't said anything
right
and this is what it's just about about
me and it's just like
and then and this is when
she left and then said well i talked to
some of my other friends and there they
understand where you're coming from and
i'm gonna give you another chance and
i'm like what like
that's kind of funny actually
yeah i think
i think if you're like reasonable you
you understand another person's point of
view so that's really odd that she just
got angry at you were you were you mean
to her like or were you just saying no
no we we
we really hit it off like like
okay
the
the first date was that to carry karaoke
this this this dive bar karaoke bar
place that i go
karaoke that's a great first date yeah
but that's a great person usually i do
i'm one of the regulars so i think she
we were singing like together like oh
and everyone's like who is the sick man
this dick is awesome like we were yet we
were we were doing good
and so it was more of like we got
wrapped up in like it would have been
a whirlwind type of
romance if you know if herpes wasn't
involved you know so and look and i i
just had to sit and be like look
i want to risk
exposing myself to this look
i'm in
i'm 40 now and in my 20s i was a little
bit reckless so i made it through the
gamut of
college and grad school and traveling
without getting any anything
yo somehow so
pearl thinks i have a kid out there
somewhere in the world i do with the
stories you were telling me
oh my god you do [ __ ] i probably
got kids on every continent [ __ ]
whatever you probably do
and you know what's crazy pearl when you
said that i always think that lately
i've been thinking about the last couple
years like
god i hope i don't have a kid but i got
a thing somewhere there's a kid that's
saying papi papi you know like
you know and so like the reason why i'm
bringing this up is because you know how
early i just said about the girl that
was withhelding her std from me
well it's crazy because the second date
that i went on her she wanted me to
smash her in the back of her car
um she had opened up to me about some
serious things that went through her
what happened to her but
she's already like spreading her legs
like full eagle you know and all of a
sudden
i said no i'm like i closed her legs and
i was like uh
she's like i just don't want to do it
here in front of you know my house or my
parents are sleeping upstairs
you know um and i don't want them to
come out and then it's just i don't want
to be your first time to be in the back
of a car
and i i literally i made her wait
for about almost like a month i made her
way almost a month
and
and it's crazy because after that
happened i got physical like okay why is
this happening to me like
why did i have to be the girl that i was
liking and then all of a sudden she
pulls and drops his bomb
in the middle of a restaurant i'm
sitting down and she's like talking
whispering that to my ear
because we're like opening it up so it
was just weird like the dynamic how that
works for me
i remember dating a woman so when i was
28 in grad grad graduate school she was
10 years older than me
and uh we were together for a while but
she was really really jealous really
really has anyone ever dated a person
that was hella jealous all yeah she she
admitted it to me in the first day she's
like i can be really jealous are you
sure you want to date me i was like
worse she admitted and i was like worse
i know pearl wants to slap me with pearl
wants to hit the stupid button on me
right now but
no
no i mean
i was just thinking don't you like
you
not i wouldn't call it cheating because
you tell her but your girlfriend now you
said you you sleep with other girls
right
yeah i'm polygamous so yeah it's
polygamous on my end but she's
monogamous on her end
and and i don't i don't do it as much as
i used to before back then like the
first couple years oh yeah don't be
gaming i was i was the bucky the white
chick slayer and like bucky the masking
chicks later like i just couldn't
imagine
i just couldn't imagine how that would
make a girl jealous so
well well
for me like to touch up on what he said
um
so marcus i'm gonna piggyback off what
you said
so you know um
backdoor car sex i guess like that was
um
yes it was with another christian girl
and like i said by the way guys i i do
not intentionally
attract these girls to me they just come
right to me i don't know why
and sometimes i'm just minding them on
business and it just happened to be
christian so
hey listen
after the first one i came on the
conclusion all you girls must just be
naughty and i just can't hold it in
that was my mindset whenever i dealt
with one one of them i'm like it must be
because you know what it is
you're a christian
go ahead
jay is because because matter of fact
there was a there was one of my exes
back in college she was this puerto
rican girl who was really fundamentalist
christian and she was a virgin we first
met and you know we had sex and
everything but i used to attract those
chicks too and the reason why is because
you're
uh there's there's a type of guy that's
that's um
that that can that
that they they don't know how to deal
with because they're like taught to stay
away from certain types of guys but then
like me
um i'm a friendly guy but at the same
time i'm edgy at the same time right so
i had just enough like
um
personality and i was just safe enough
to kind of start talking to her and then
all the other stuff was all you know so
she first first drank for the first time
with me and you know when you know
stayed out faster curfew with me
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i could so that
and i was like man i keep attracting all
these hella christian girls this is kind
of odd you know what i'm saying so you
know what we call you but you know what
we call religious girls we call i call
them angel fruitcakes so cause to me
they're angel food cake
it's a religious girl
i don't get it
[Laughter]
what they've been saving but they're
they're supposed to be angels yeah
they're chastity's a cake
yeah
this is what i've noticed about like
because i grew up in the church and um
i also went to like a pretty like i
would say like pretty intense church in
milwaukee and i've noticed there's two
types of girls there's the girls that go
there because
well there's more than two types but two
that i'm going to talk about um the
girls that go because they've done
something bad
and like they like want to feel better
because like christians like you can be
saved no matter what you've done or
there's the types that like just grew up
in it and like believe in it actually
um
and so that's why like guys will always
say oh like christian girls can be wild
too i'm like duh that's why there's
christian mingle so there's
christianity.com
yeah i'm a former christian so i i
actually think i actually do i have a
better consensus on it now than i did
before but now it's like okay dude i
think i i understand now fully why they
went to me specifically i get it now
because
they want you to be their wesley snipes
that too probably but i i left that in
the other bottom of the totem pole at
the time because um i think i just i was
just doing sports more i guess i just
got more noticeable at that time because
like i said once once i got into sports
things just changed rapidly like it went
from yeah zero to 160 like literally and
i'm just like okay guys
like because girls yeah cause girls look
at you as the lion king of the jungle
like when you're in high school yeah
they look at you as the lion kings
because when i was in sports i was in
football wrestling basketball like i was
doing these sports and it just it helped
you with social circles it helped you
communicate better you end up building
up bonds with men and like like the
brotherhood and then they
the guys that are more attractive than
you they'll attract women that are
attractive and some of them will fall
your way if you're like you know
and the whole school exalts the the guys
that play sports like i was on the
wrestling team and the football ball tv
even though our football team was
absolute trash like we were out there
oh you understand and we would just
smash and just especially so we had a
lot of mormon chicks uh
more and more i used to live
man
man [ __ ]
i probably got some [ __ ] half black
mormon babies out there somewhere
reproductive rights though we have zero
reproductive rights you girls also
choose if you want to keep the baby okay
okay okay okay here hear me out condoms
okay no
condoms are only 76 a percent
effective when you factor in user error
now
marcus was telling me that he he was
finishing and when brandon women i'm
like why would you take that chance like
when you could
i bought the plan i literally had stacks
of plan b pills just in case if i'd be
on demon time
i'd be like feast right you could do
this
i was craving the hunt i was craving the
hunter they were my prey
well that was the argument that you told
yourself [ __ ] pregnant it will ruin
your life that is not working it will
you guys you should know
red pill you should know more than
than anyone
listen pearl you are not going to try to
lecture me now after you told me you
want to start your fab five you're
starting fight for the nba you want to
have like a starting point okay okay
okay you know what you know what you
can't you can say what you want but when
my kids are in the nba and i'm courtside
let's just like oh so now you want to be
the lebron james girl
i want to be like that ball family
where they just like no you don't you're
not that guy they have favorites you
don't think they have favorites come on
come on um
you see what you're doing
you're putting the basketball on the
pedestal that's what you're doing yeah
yeah i mean that was yours
yeah
yeah
she wants athletes bro she wants that
yeah she yeah if she hears this like she
knows she said it
i'm like okay she's serious
she wants to go she wants to
why would i put these jeans to waste i'm
just she wants to put she wants to take
her kids
she wants to take her kids to foot
locker she wants to take her kids to
champs she wants to take kids to
basketball camp everything sports was
the best thing that ever happened to me
like literally growing up as an athlete
was the best thing that ever happened to
me and i absolutely
well
it's fun until it's fun sports is fun
until politics get involved that's when
it stops being fun it's too much
politics
yeah it sounds like someone who quit
because they didn't get to play no no i
didn't quit no one i never questioned
the football team and coach's son got
got to be quarterback even though he was
trash
exactly
i believe that he
every single set of politics that like
you possibly could literally one time i
got all tournament i led the team in
kills i love the team in blocks i could
not lead the team in any other stat and
then i got benched the next game let me
ask you something pearl let me ask you
something let me ask you something
because you were raised
pretty well off because your parents
made good money right
yeah so they could afford to take you to
camps and forge you to take you to get
trainers that forge you to buy the the
nice expensive healthy foods volleyball
you literally can't play volleyball
unless you have a certain amount of
money because you have to know i'm just
forgetting forget about it yeah but what
i mean is you were able to get do you
were able to get pushed to go to the
training camps paid for those pay for
the trainers paid for the nutrition pay
for stuff like that so you got that step
up that bump up where it helps you as an
athlete as an individual a lot of a lot
of people in general they don't have the
money like that they don't have the
currency like that to afford things like
that
yeah and the connections
have to do with like because it helps
you with your skills it helps you with
your skills it helps you get better
no but you're talking about politics i
hate it when people do that when it's
like
yeah we're talking about politics but
it's like oh you grew up privileged so
you can't talk about it no no no no no
no no no no no no no no you're not
hearing me you're not hearing me though
you're not hearing me because the head
coach
i'm not putting you in a box pearl i'm
not i'm what i'm saying what i'm saying
is the head coach if he wants his
handshake he wants his handshake with
some nice endorsements and sponsorships
no that never happened
not where i played no no i'm saying like
it doesn't matter what the politics are
like there's always going to be politics
in life like people have favorites
that's just life
and in this situation even with like my
parents having money i wasn't the
favorite i literally got all tournament
like i got the award for being like one
of the best people at the tournament and
i sat for three games like you cannot
say that has nothing to do with politics
participation oh [ __ ]
what
what participation that's because you
said you said you got a participation
award
no no no no no it's not a participation
award it's like because basically what
happened was i was um
i didn't start that game like i wasn't
playing and they put me in the game off
the bench and i led the team in kills
and blocks and i got like the all
tournament awards so they only give that
to like three or four girls in an entire
tournament so i was one of the best i
played one of the bet like at the
tournament i was one of the best people
and still the next game i didn't play
for three
yeah that's what i'm saying like that
that was politics
and
yeah it was really imp it was really
weird
i'm pretty sure they put like the names
in a raffle and then they started
rolling in it's like we'll go with her
no no it was it's a long story but
basically
coaches do do make something they do
[ __ ] like that but i'm saying that's
live so i don't like why would i not
have my kids play sports because okay
like things that happen in the real
world like bosses have favorites
everybody has favorites for whatever
cats
let me tell you let me tell you
something
if because a little bit of a pearl is
saying a little bit true but like i said
and one of my streams i did like two
weeks ago when it's when i thought about
um confidence and experience as women
sports can't elevate you to be a little
bit better than what you were before
because i would never be able to speak
the way that i am speaking now like the
confidence is just really ridiculous
once you get it
is it ridiculous more ridiculous to the
point when you have your own when you're
on a swim team you also have the girls
with you because they represent the team
other way
and one of them
and one of them literally goes that do
you have sex with them
so there's a lot of benefits that come
with if you're a dude if you're a dude
if you're a girl you have a crush on a
guy and you're in sports that's the
benefit there too because most likely he
won't say no i don't know
for me it just taught me how to like
work hard at something and like chase
after goals like like i was i was really
bad when i started i was the worst there
at our club there are teams and it's
like first team second team third i was
the third i didn't even play and by my
senior year i was starting on the first
and it just taught me that like if you
work hard at something and you chase
after it like good things tend to happen
did you start your junior year too
my of what high school or college
uh well you're talking high school was
that when you're seeing yeah i was well
i was talking in high school so it was
like
so so i'm saying like in the club
season um
like i started on
the third team and i wasn't playing and
by my senior year i was on like the
first team and then i got a ton of
playing time
oh okay okay yeah so that was you moved
up in the depth chart is what you're
saying you moved up yeah yeah
but like
i don't know it just it teaches you a
lot so yeah michael it's supposed to
it's supposed to it's supposed to teach
you respect discipline yeah discipline
yeah
she did for me
and even
even like when stuff like favoritism
happens like it teaches you that life
isn't fair and that you have to work
with people even if they don't like you
yeah
learn that the hard way that's true
and if if their favorite gets hurt then
it's your time to rise up
yeah oh no no definitely marcus i
actually fought one of them and after
that we became friends
okay
welcome to the chat guys what is your
crazy dating story
uh yeah uh
uh unless dc you want to go first let's
uh give me a second
i ain't even had to have i i haven't had
any crazy i've had any crazy dates i was
going to talk about how you was talking
about the christian camp how you went to
one or something like that
one time i was sitting there
i went to church and
i'm sitting here listening to a sermon
and they was talking about sexual sin
and we just sitting up there listening
to it and towards the end the dude who's
the lead pastor gets up there and he
says this he says you know we're gonna
do it old school man
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna have the
prayer team come up in front of the
church and anybody who wants prayer
anybody who wants to confess anything
you just walk up to the front and just
say what you need to say if you're not
comfortable with it that's fine you can
leave but we're going to kick it old
school today and we're just going to
have that moment if anyone's not
comfortable you can leave but we're
going to award this opportunity to
anybody
now i'm gonna tell you something
the people that i was in the bible study
with the people who i just seen at the
church before you know my girlfriend's
friend
like i am seeing people cry
all over this church i mean almost this
was no small church
almost the whole church was crying i'm
over here seeing people
falling out their head down one of these
my bible studies just sitting on the
steps at the front just looking like
this right here with tears going down
his eyes and i'm just walking around
thinking
what the heck have you people done
and that that's just something that i
thought of once you once you said that
sometimes it's not what they've done
though sometimes it's what they've been
through as well that's true yeah
yeah
because we've been talking about like
some people that might be homosexuals
and so like that's something too i
thought about as well
oh yeah
oh sorry brooke's my best friend she
gets to cut everybody
oh excuse me then
yep yeah mac that's how it is over here
mark is trying to flame her earlier
she was trying to flame me earlier i was
trying to flame her back
[Music]
hey brooke
hi
how are you
i'm i'm good i'm so cold because my
heater broke
what's your crazy dating story do you
have one has anything happened to you
recently you've been going on dates
um
kind of i've been canceling most of them
i had
like
one guys
okay
well okay the last like accident went on
he um he didn't know like what to say so
he just started talking about like other
like just like girls that he's met in
his life
yeah but he would i was like i don't
know like if you're trying to jealous or
what
talking about like um going to the strip
club and like the girls that he saw
there and i was like
okay that's cool but then he would like
get into detail and be like so they did
this this and this and the lap dance
and i was like you don't like have to
talk about this if you don't want to
like
that's how that's how the
um i don't think he knew his name that's
how the old guy was
he yeah
he would tell me about all of his
exes i'm like i don't
why but i think they do it because they
think it'll make you like
like want them more because i don't i
don't i don't know why they do it the
other the other i've never heard that
i'm like
i haven't really i've heard that like
the more you talk about it the less i
believe you
well i i'm like
yeah he would tell how he's like um
like the like girls like he's like lived
with in his life like wanted to hook up
with him while he was living with them
and he was like and i was like okay like
do you love the girl now and he's like
no no me and my
dog like
okay and he's like we have berlin
co-parenting
and then i don't know it was weird it
was just
he just wanted you as part of the roster
that's probably not like oh but the
worst part was like eventually he was
like oh do you wanna have a drink i was
like no i think i'm gonna head out
because like
like i'm tired or whatever
um and he dropped that n-word like four
times and he is very white i like in the
middle of this bar
and i was like whoa and he was like i'm
just telling a story
so then
i was like okay well i have to go my
roommate's outside i like laughs sounds
like he sounds like riffraff
i got a question okay you said that
most of the dates that you cancelled
so
you met these guys no i like i've
canceled like all my hinge digs pretty
much
what's a hinge date so i don't like that
like a dating app
okay i thought you meant like in person
stuff
nah
i if i know someone looks a little
different
but it's like weird i don't know i feel
like nobody has been on with like
i want to hear i want to hear a story
where a person canceled in person you
know like hey i'm cancelling this date
right in front of your face because
you're right there
i wanna
oh no
pearl what's your thoughts on that
what's your thoughts on brooks
experience
oh no
oh god um
um brooks experience
what canceling on guys
or the
brooks on brooke's day
oh he sounds like a pimp
i think you shouldn't see him again
oh that's good because i didn't
yeah right she's probably got him back
in the roster to pay for her dinner
dates
i'm actually a big believer and if i
don't want to sleep again i usually pay
for my portion because then i like don't
feel like i have to see him at all
that's cap
that is not cap
give her a chance
oh no she makes hella money she's an
engineer she doesn't know a word
okay bro let me ask you a question okay
because because you're an engineer i
want to know this okay
if a man makes
twenty thousand dollars less than you
and he's financial
okay if someone makes twenty thousand
dollars less than what you make are they
well financial stability is more about
how you take care of your money if he
makes 20 000 less than you
would you turn him down just for that no
and when i say would you turn down for
that i don't mean like you know the kind
of like under not saying this is you but
like the underhanded you know
he had this and he did that but really
it was the money that was the issue
well if he made 20 000 less than me he'd
still make a lot of money like so i
don't see
like that wouldn't be an issue i mean
like he'd still be able to make a normal
living i don't really care how much
someone makes as long as they can
support themselves because i just don't
like to pay for people if i don't like
like for their lifestyle i guess
like everyone else
yeah but but the guy's money is both
yours and his money your money is your
money isn't it isn't that how it works
no
no i don't share anything
you don't share okay yeah
did you study mechanical engineering by
chance no i did industrial manufacturing
uh okay so i'm mechanical right now i'm
trying to graduate in here in may so
oh cool yeah
yeah uh where you go to school
uh uga we [ __ ] won that's all i gotta
say go dogs
oh yeah national champions
congratulations
mack what's your crazy dating story i
think i've shared this a little bit but
uh yeah i mean first someone got laid it
was it's from speaking only german and
uh
what was it
i think it was was it twitter it was uh
was it hinge it was
a [ __ ] what's it called it's
it was some dating app and like yeah i'm
some black guy you know just in georgia
you know not really any as far as i know
i don't know it could be like some great
great grandpa probably from germany who
knows but like yeah at the time i was uh
very close to fluid in german
completely in german
and like yes my story on like how i got
my
that's how i first got laid
do you speak do you still speak german
uh and i i lost it from time uh and
actually
that's the crazy thing that's not not
even my first foreign language is first
french and uh went over to france for a
while and i gotta say like like going to
france like they they could they were
able to tell that i was american but i
don't know if they were like impressed
but like like people were like
definitely looking like oh damn it's
like this obviously american guy like
speaking like pretty good friend so i
guess i could also be like another game
just like i don't know move to a
different country and be like
do that so
i don't know not that interesting but i
i thought it was worth sharing so
no no no mac that's cool um i actually
got a girl from japan to uh
speak to me and go out with me because i
speak a little bit of japanese now i
actually know how to fully speak it so
it's actually not that weird
that you know that she liked you and
actually got the
you actually get to live with her
because you actually know um you know
german language so that's actually cool
dude
yeah yeah jay's told me about that he
wants to give her his sushi roll yeah
of course stop
and like mine was just like japanese no
i
i can only imagine how hard those are
because it's like completely different
scrub i actually got two you got kana
and uh
uh
yeah
katakana and uh
what was that
kansai kanzai oh sorry it's like damn so
at least like german and french are in
latin so it's like i don't have to learn
anything new yeah because i was about to
i was about to speak to you in german
right now
i was like
uh
you know uh
stuttgart
i lived in germany for three months
but i didn't pick up on and on as much
as it as i would have liked to uh
which part of germany if he could uh was
it
i lived in berlin and then this town
called hotchka in northern germany for
it was like half the summer i lived in
one town half the summer i lived in the
other i think german girls are freaks
though they i shout out to my german
girls because
man you go to amsterdam you go to uh
uh i go to denmark i've been to munich
i've been a student um yeah so those are
great places
i can't comment other than he's not
lying
but uh
but yeah i only ask because like it's
like really interesting because like you
can actually tell if you're like really
fluent or personal you can tell where
someone's from just from like their
german accent there's like people from
like bavaria to like munich or i used to
say much and then i realized oh [ __ ]
it's actually called munich and uh
english so
like those people
i was gonna say how else is dating going
for you
i
i
um it's not right now i just kind of
ended it with like all the things
and now i'm just chilling
bro let me ask you something let me ask
you something
um
because you said your engineer i just
got i just got i just got questions now
just eight questions stop popping up to
me
out of all the well first how old are
you uh
26. 26 okay
i don't mean to be offensive at all
yeah you do
no i mean if i was gonna antagonize her
i wouldn't have said that i would just
say what i got to say
um
why
had why has no one i'm not saying i'm
i'm really just asking you why has no
one been good enough for you
because
you seem like a
nice person you don't have an attitude
at least right here
you're an attractive person
so
why has no one been good enough for you
well i was in a relationship for like
and
it was like i started when i was really
young so
i think i didn't really know any better
because it started when i was like 20.
it was like really shitty but like when
you're in it you don't always like
realizing shitty you know what i mean
i think that like held me back and then
once i realized like you have to be done
with it sort of thing and like broke it
off it's like you don't want to like
date seriously again you know
define define shitty in your eyes
because women have a broad spectrum of
saying oh it's shitty holding you back
so can you get a detailed into that if
you don't think it was healthy we did i
mean we argued a lot
he was jealous because i was an engineer
he was a business major and
yeah he was and like i never minded i
don't know anything about it well that's
what because you said you would
you would be jealous that you made more
money than him you didn't even make it a
big deal yeah
yeah well he would i would tell him what
jobs i was applying to and he was like
well why don't you apply to this one and
i was like oh well i'm over qualified
i'm overpowered just like not like being
mean it's like i'm literally
overqualified for it
i did this job like you think you're too
good for this job and it's like
no
he was an insecure child
i thought that [ __ ] ended in college
like the whole business major versus
stem well like damn like what the [ __ ] i
don't know i don't know i was a business
major engineers are better than us i
don't know what like
there's a lot of there's a lot of dumb
aspects in my school like i'm just going
to say it straight up
i'm like
i'm like please tell your fee because
like if you practice along with doesn't
make it all over [ __ ] units but yeah
but mac that's not what she means what
she means is because stem actually gives
and goes back to the society of it like
also you know science technology
engineering math they all are building
blocks and layers for society to be
built
people get organized because like any
like engineering club on campus is like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] show like
like the later skills are like zero so
well not many not many people can be
leaders though not many are leaders it's
very few it can be
um brooke what is the brooklyn what is
the main issue with the men that you go
on dates with
um
i mean
so i think that's the problem is a lot
of like
so i i work with like mainly guys and
i've like because i'm also in the
national guard so like i'm around guys
most of the time and so the problem is i
feel like it's always
like friends
or like co-workers
that want to date me and it's like
that's not the kind of environment i
want to be in so it's like hard to meet
and like they're not gonna like
introduce me to their friends or
anything so it's like hard to meet
people like outside like guys outside of
what i work with unless it's like
they're dating actually like going out
but
um
and then you work so much it's like you
you how much of a connection are you
gonna build with someone you meet like
what a couple hours a week like one or
two
yeah so it's like i don't know and i
don't i don't want to date like people
that i work with
um i just think that leads to like
issues
yeah i tell i always i always teach the
guys that i know be around like don't
ever hook up with girls in your work or
date them because for the most part a
lot of them don't work out together and
then i understand from you because i'm a
former service member myself
but that's why i never dated any other
girl marines
because for one i don't want to be
around that lot that long in that
environment and i want to kind of
leave home and i will leave work and go
home and not
be kind of reminded that
from my point of view i just don't want
to be reminded of it all the time
yeah
and
uh thank you thank you thank you for
your service as well because i
appreciate it
yeah much appreciate it yeah and i've
also heard if you're uh once your girl
goes to basic she's basically single so
uh
oh yeah girl girls are getting their
backs going out yeah a lot but i know a
lot of military girls that get their
best friend
what was that what was that
known for cheating i would never
that's what they call the girls are
boning jody you know that's the whole
saying
jody
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god that one guy
do you remember he was that you were at
basic with the news
hitting on
me on the live stream
on the facetime yeah and he he's married
and like oh [ __ ] i didn't know that he's
married
he's like am i not your type and i'm
like i don't know my type is usually not
man
like single
say less say less
he was like why would you tell her that
i was like that's my friend do you want
me to lie to her like over you
i mean i mean
and plus i'm that big i will i i will be
i'm the girl don't you think that's
funny though that girls have a certain
code but then like the girl code will
get mad if guy code is being loyal to
their own guys
like if the chick is doing something bad
like the guys will be like definitely
look it out but i've noticed a hypocrisy
sometimes in women's girl code
why would you dare mess up my bag or why
would you dare mess up my sugar baby
like i've seen
[Music]
oh i said my friends don't cheat on
their boyfriends so
oh
[ __ ] hey
your friends cheat on your their
boyfriends
um i don't think that not any
she's already covering she's already
covering
oh [ __ ]
i've been around people that cheat but i
don't think any like specific
like
i guess i don't know that was someone
that i'd consider a friend i've seen a
lot of people around me that cheat
but not like i don't know
this is like csi
i ain't gonna lie i'm looking at one of
my old friends my old roommate too i'm
looking at them a different way now yeah
bro how did you do that
yeah
so pearl this is a question for pearl
and brook since they're the ladies here
at the panel and this is pearl street i
might have a question do you girls have
a laundry list of checks that your men
have to meet
how long is the laundry last i
hey because on the average women have a
decent amount of checkbox
i'll tell you what i look for i was
going to say hannah or pill
i
like the guy i'm six foot so i prefer
that is 5 10 or taller
i feel like that's what he's going to
block if he's 5 11. is that cool is that
he's five or less yeah oh yeah that's
fine
but your kids won't be that tall though
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait dc
but yeah they haven't finished it dc i
want the girls to finish what you said
oh let's go ahead jesus
yeah okay 510 does he have to have money
on can he just be 510 or does he have to
have no i don't i don't care about money
i don't the money doesn't matter i care
if you work hard and you're passionate
about something
i would marry i always say i would marry
a coach
it's not about money it's about like
okay
yeah the coaches go through so much
stress
my dad i lived with my dad he was
stressed out all the time like
it's really attractive to me when
someone's passionate and they work hard
at something it's not it's not about
money
and especially for me i'm in a position
where like
i know past a certain age like i'll be
okay because of like my family so i
don't i don't want to matter to me
no i'm just it's just honest um hey
it's just what what are what are other
what are other check marks that need to
we'll need to be checked i want the same
politics and the it doesn't have to be
the same religion but like somewhat
similar like christian catholic
something like that okay okay
or just doesn't care i just want my kids
to be raised in a church and i want to
be the same politics are you a roman
catholic or are you like i like
latter-day saints is that where you
well i grew up catholic and i went to
catholic school but i i went to a
christian church the past couple of
years
so i i'm cool with either i'm not like i
don't have superheroes oh okay so it's
not one okay so one doesn't dominate the
other okay all right uh i can get behind
that
i feel like there's a fifth one i feel
like there's five things i look for and
i meant so many catholic girls that are
freaks though it's so it's not even
funny
i can't remember what the fifth one is
no kid that's been a recent thing oh
[ __ ] she wants she wants to know jodie's
from baby boy she wants them baby boys
i personally don't think that's crazy
no that's fine it's respectful
you're hanging out and he's like mommy
mommy like what the [ __ ]
i feel like there's a fifth thing and i
just can't remember what it is
but i guess that's not that important if
i can't remember
something
i haven't i haven't i haven't heard
brooke's list yet yeah so
brooke's last like she's actually i
would say because you think that's a lot
right don't you
no i don't that's a lot of fun
no that's fine
it's fine i forgot it used to be i
didn't want a guy that was like yeah you
used to have like a huge thing no i
didn't it broke no i didn't it was those
five things it was just like if i found
out brooke is exposing you
just friends
hey dc now you know why i say stop the
cat
this is my platform okay
and
respectfully
brooke
no i one it was always those five things
what else maybe
if a guy didn't have one of those five
things then i would just be like yeah
no like if he was like not the same
politics i'd be like oh no next i didn't
feel like he worked hard
[Music]
but pearl when you say that as long as
he's like i'm trying to because females
will say this and i'm just trying to i'm
trying to get down to what you're what
you're really trying to say
when a female says i want a guy who's
hard-working and is just passionate
about what he does let's say if i'm hard
working on just building skateboards and
i'm passionate about skateboarding
that's what i love i don't care about
money
what does hard work and passion lead to
that's what i'm saying so like when you
say you don't care about money and then
say hard work and passion it has to be
really hard working and passionate
that's the same thing as saying make a
lot of money because that's what that's
true i was gonna not but
but not but not always that's what i'm
saying if you become a coach coaches
don't typically make a lot of money
so i've always said that i would marry a
coach because that's something where
they work really hard it's long hours
and they don't make a lot of money
but it's like college coaches
college coaches make a lot of money
college coaches and division one even
some in division two make a lot of money
i know
do you feel like that's the exception or
the rule i just haven't found that call
like coaching for that for that job
demographic for that job demographic at
that level just like you could separate
tax brackets
division one and division two coaches
especially if they're the main football
coach that's their star program that
covers the school they're going to make
a lot of money just like if you were to
cover if basketball is not good at
school they're going to make a lot of
money right and i know you're into that
yeah well not i actually don't watch
sports
no no i want my kids to play sports but
i actually don't watch sports okay
that's the funny part um like
i get bored i can't i just have better
things to do
but
um no to me it like you could use a
different industry then like fine don't
use coaching use a different industry
like a musician but to me again it's
about being oh no you want a musician
okay oh hold on no no stop stop because
you're construing like all i the only
reason i said coach is because that's an
example of an industry that i have found
that doesn't make a ton of money so i
don't care what the industry is
as long as they work hard and they're
passionate about something
that's the only reason i use coaching i
don't i don't know a ton about coaching
yeah yeah i wasn't trying to catch you
up i was going to ask like okay
uh like is if he's a magician right like
so
if he's like at least one of the guys
back in the day will like pass up the cd
he's about like linux or something i
mean that's that's working hard but it's
but what i'm i think i can it's like it
can be like hard work it doesn't have to
be like a millionaire but it can't be
like some [ __ ] like
it can't just be like
oh yeah i'm trying to you know get my
new mixtape drop
and it's dusty you know what i'm saying
well yeah but i just i just have this
belief where if you do something for
five years in your perspective you're
gonna be better than most people at it
you're probably i'm not saying every
single person is gonna make it rich and
like hit the lottery and make millions
but
like you really think if you do the same
thing for five ten years you're going to
be broke and not better than most people
at it
there's so many people that are doing
that that still don't make it though
i was gonna no offense like i understand
what you're saying you have to define
make it
you know you see how you're like i don't
know i don't know many people i don't
know many people that worked 80 hours a
week for five to ten years eighty hours
of god damn that's when my dad worked he
worked 80 hours
my whole life that's half of your time
that's half of a week
when i was when i used to left two hours
a night oh my gosh no he didn't
he didn't i was gonna say my father my
father worked like 60 hour a week
sometimes and you're not i thought that
was the house
my dad was running his own business and
i would help my dad run this business
because i was the one that would set up
the estimates do the work within the
labor and then like do all the
estimations the numbers everything i
wouldn't help them with that
yeah man
like i'm not it's not an exact like
number
of hours i'm ju all i'm saying is like
most people that i've found that work
hard at something and do it for a long
time tend to be good at it and make
money i'm not saying that's every single
case
but like that tends to come with hard
work and for long hours i'll get you on
that though
i'm not trying to nitpick over how many
hours or what industry like i think
that's you know
well
what about yours brooke what's your list
brooke
because i haven't heard yours at all
and works out like three times a week
you say what okay daddy works out three
times a week and he's funny that's like
every guy that goes to the gym basically
and no but not like an [ __ ] anymore
like a hype man like someone's going to
hype you up
you want dj khaled
i mean you don't work out though so i
mean just keep it a buck
rick ross lost weight he's funny i think
okay
hey brooke what does the guy that you
want what does he want from you
um
from me i would hope
that
i guess like i don't know someone that
he could laugh with
i just i just like i feel like i vibe
well when like i can laugh a lot with
someone
so i would hope he'd want the same for
me and then also i would hope that he'd
want me to like go out and do things
because i like um i'm not very good at
just like sitting so like i don't know
like hiking i ski a lot or like
going like out to dinner um or just like
cooking in general or and also he has to
like want someone who likes wine
um
and whiskey because he wants a bougie
don't you you like them
bro
[Laughter]
do you want the guy to be all that for
you brooke
i mean he doesn't have to be all that
but like that's what i'm isn't that
supposed to be the other way around
somebody who goes and does stuff
that's like when you when you started
off with hopefully
you lost
yeah you said hopefully like
you the problem you made is you went on
the dating market not having a clue men
really don't care if you're funny they
don't care if you want to go out places
that's a bonus but men do not care at
all that's how you want us to make you
feel when we approach you well what do
they care about then
we care about somebody who's cooperative
submissive and agreeable somebody who
doesn't give us a hard time and stresses
yeah no headache
one piece the woman's job is that's the
piece of the man won't much at all we
don't want much at all cooperate with us
submit to us
agreeableness and just don't give us a
headache that's literally it
i'm we're literally giving you the
manual broke
that's that
you see can i ask you a question
[Laughter]
we literally are dc dc put it to you
real respectful real calmly
listen just like in biblical times
ancient times uh you go back all the way
to the eras all these men all these men
that were leaders that were the men of
men that brought back the food that
fought the wars all they wanted was a
peaceful home like that you know it's
the what's that saying in the bible a
man would rather be alone sleeping alone
than with a quarrelsome woman
like of course like that's the same
place you cannot you cannot be that
quarrelsome
exactly yeah like you don't want to go
home to a storm and you know be full on
like vegeta versus frieza like we don't
want to deal with that kind of stuff you
know like we don't want that is that
what she's doing now i'm kidding yeah no
no no i'm lost too i'm not alive no he
was just giving her examples
it just sounds like they want someone
who like will never
like basically
say anything
like if if it's not going to agree with
you
no we're not saying that we didn't
you're not listening
okay what we're talking about
we're talking about your overall
general demeanor when we say agreeable
and submissive
what we're talking about is the same way
how you may not agree with your teachers
and your boss
but you still carry a certain level of
respect for him and how you're not gonna
go off at the mouth you're gonna bring
it to him respectfully and if you can't
do that you're just gonna sit back
that's what we're talking about we're
not saying don't never say that we don't
want that because then we can real stuff
we're talking about
your general
demeanor just like how you do with your
boss or your co-worker when you don't
agree with them you don't just go
rambling off you don't just pitch a fit
or ignore them you know what i'm saying
you'll suggest i don't think that's
right because of this um maybe i'll go
over here maybe we should sign up for
counseling or this that or the other or
if you're gonna do this this is really
messed up and i know it i can't follow
that that's when you back out that's
what we're talking about it's the same
vice versa though
like that you can come to partner in a
respectful manner i need you to
understand something real quick brooke i
need to understand like listen we're not
saying you can't have your opinion i
could ask you hey what's your opinion on
this like if we were a couple like babe
what what do you think about this like
how should we do this or that like i
don't know this way if you were to ask
for your pen that's cool but
the thing about it is you don't want to
have to hold face a headache and a
problem and fight or argue and be
constant like in a constant flux you
know like
there can't be no two ceos to a business
there can't be two presidents to a
country there's a president and a vice
president there's a ceo and a vice
president so you need to understand that
there are roles to play just like i have
my role as a man you would have your
role as the woman now does that mean
that i'm going to overtalk you and and
put you down and have you in shackles no
that's not what it means what it means
is hey the man the man is the one that's
the leader the man is going to lead but
you got to understand i get it i tell
the guys too you got to be a man that's
worth following you can't be a bum or a
loser or a jackass or a degenerate yeah
and that's your fault brooke if you pick
those guys because you pick them in just
like you have the power and the control
to your sex to open your legs we have
the power for relationships and marriage
as men we do not the woman because the
woman isn't going to be the one
proposing women don't want to be born
proposing they want to be proposed too
just like what that that there's that uh
symbolism when the father is walking his
daughter that's daddy's little princess
even and it shouldn't even be like that
but that's daddy's little princess in
this analogy and he's get and he's
giving you off
to your man which is your king that man
is your king when you marry
that's all i'm saying
okay i mean that's fine if thanks to
your opinion i just don't think there's
it's not opinion that's not opinion
that's like symbolism that's not opinion
of symbolism
i think it's just compromising in
general so like
if someone didn't agree with my opinion
i would want that or like didn't like
something i did i'd want them to tell me
and be like really rude if you did this
i don't appreciate it
and i'd say okay respect that and then i
would think it's the same vice versa
that i could go to them and say hey i
didn't appreciate the way you did well i
think brooke i think what he's trying to
say is like
when you're in a relationship like
somebody has to make the decisions
because when there's a decision to be
made it's either your way or his way if
you guys disagree who does it come down
to
well like then what happens in like that
what is i mean what and that's the thing
and that's the thing man it's like
society has really programmed that
a woman's role is because brooke is like
from what i'm getting and she's pearl
friend
she's pearls from pearl school just from
what i'm getting from her too brooke is
not a mo she can be mean if she wants to
maybe she's done some stuff in the past
but brooke is not a mean belligerent out
to hate get men person and she still has
she knows exactly what marcus is talking
about but she still doesn't emotionally
accept it that's how deeply this is
ingrained in our society that poor man
well i just i think sometimes like i
think sometimes people just like don't
agree you know like people
like like people want different types of
relationships and as much as like the
ideal especially in the manosphere is
like
the um
i don't know the traditional housewife
more like in the man being the protector
and provider it's not reality like how
many relationships do you know where
like the man's the stamp and the woman
like leads it happens happens all the
time a lot of people choose that yeah
that's why
that's why 50 of marriages are failing
or oh exactly yeah
i'm kind of noticing like uh like not on
everything but like i'm playing i am
like like only guy who's kind of like
sitting here like uh with a few things
just i don't necessarily agree but um
i would say like i mean with do you see
why she said um
i get i get like like when i'm at sphere
and red poke eyes they say like that's
like submits submission
and being agreeable i mean a lot of
that's just not being dead like
i just think that like in a marriage the
ladies like to hook up and date dicks
though
um oh yeah some do
well and in a marriage i just think like
i don't know i can't i can see both
sides of a lot of things and like i i
think it's silly to think you're never
going to have to compromise even if
you're the like leader in a relationship
nobody left that out yeah yeah yeah
trust me
i know but i'm telling you i'm telling
you wait wait i'm telling you just how
it comes off a lot of times when like
you don't so it's how you feel it comes
off also
no
no because like do you do you imagine
like the president or like the ceo
compromising that much with their
superiors like no it's usually like what
they want to do
i mean what marcus is talking about is
we we never said that you don't have to
compromise or anything like that we're
just giving base ground rules is all and
yeah i'm not trying to be offensive i'm
not trying to come at you i'm just
saying what's happening like you and
brooke took that and turned into
something else we were just laying
ground foundation that's what he's
talking about
yeah well what i'm saying is like it's
like i agree with you guys but i'm
telling you when you're not when you're
not redtail like like when you don't
know this stuff like this is how it
sounds like that's what i'm saying oh no
that's fair that's fair pearl but like
we're not disagreeing with you on that
and the thing is
the touch-up on dc and my men marcus
what they're saying like listen
i don't and this is why something i'll
understand because i'm a 91 kid and i
just can't fathom that people think
submission means collaring chain you got
to stop that you're not a slave well you
gotta go no it's like i always say it's
like picking a ceo it's like picking a
company you're gonna work for like
that's what i think of when i think of
submission
you gotta go with the words that people
know like if 90 people think a certain
word means one thing you can't be like
oh well i actually mean this it's just
like and you got to go with the language
like i use red-filled terms all the time
you know i really agree with it because
i just go with what people know
so like if most people when you say
submission they think like damn all
right try being a [ __ ] slave that's
how you gotta walk so you do you guys do
no submission a lot of cultures and
religion submission is a sign of
strength coming from a woman do you guys
know that
yeah this is a mission in cultures and
religions it's a sign of pure strength
from the woman i don't know to give to a
man
yeah i don't she can fight this problem
what's the mission
no problem we're not saying that you do
or yeah maybe brooke doesn't either
because um like i said from like like
what dc was saying when he explained
brooke i agree with the brother because
brooke doesn't give that off can read
people's atmosphere i'm really good at
doing this when i when i talk to a girl
i'm able to read her atmosphere to see
what type of energy she's putting off
and if it comes off crooked then that
means there's there's something foul at
work or something that's like lacking
her the same thing would apply to me if
she's trying to read me there's
something off about you jay okay that's
fair
i i'll let it be like that but the
difference is i think
we're not saying you can't compromise
our relationship these i know what i
know dc's thinking
he's literally saying like yes we can
compromise in a relationship but the
difference is yeah you're going to make
the decisions but doesn't mean that you
can't come to talk to me when we're
having discussing something big if we're
going to move to like kentucky or
something of course we're going to talk
about that i'm not going to say yo bro
get up we got to go to kentucky i'm not
going to say that we're going to talk
about it of course i'm not going to
leave it's going to be a plan yeah well
yeah exactly again i always say it's
like picking a c
it's picking what company you're going
to work for
yeah and like women what i'm saying is
like well what i'm saying is like
there's a lot of middle ground and
middle ground relationships where like
like that's just not reality like that's
not the typical relationship where the
woman submits to the husband there's a
lot yeah
i wanted to add this i wanted to add
this too because a lot of people get it
twisted where
both a man and a woman think that
marriage is about happiness it's no
marriage is about duty it's it's
literally in the vows it's literally
about duty responsibilities and
especially if you have kids before even
marriage it's even especially more about
duties i think it's more important to
have duties in peace and harmony then
can have the happiness because we get it
relationships you're gonna argue you
might might disagree
but if you can overall agree or the man
is the leader the man has to be worth
following but the woman have to be also
be cooperative and follow that man's
lead
that's what i'm saying
you know brooke no i agree with you
brooke are you still there yeah i don't
i haven't seen her for a minute yeah
like yeah i'm blank
i think she's on her phone
i'm saying this for actual real life
you're 26
and you're trying to get married
no i'm not
i don't like to share remember
there we go well it's it's four guys
here
we just when you started saying what the
men that you want
all four of us
had something to say and we chimed in
and stopped you the guy that you want
when you get on a date with him
everything you just said it didn't fly
once
you were married the guy who's looking
to marry and have his kids with you what
you said and just
that's not gonna fly with him
something in your past that made you
make a decision or like did you talk
about anything about it probably like
basically
raising my brothers
and now i have oh okay can you spend it
on other people
okay
also a little bit y'all kind of
self-included me like i'm not saying or
bad people but i i didn't really have a
i wasn't really that pressed like she
can like
if it's what she wants like i said like
i said anybody can make their own
decisions the way they want it trust me
i'm not like i said if one thing i
encourage free will more than anybody
because i like i don't like anybody
being under restraints that's always
been my thing in my mindset but when it
comes to relationship that's a little
bit different the difference is you both
you both have the key role what to do
because you both if you both decide to
have children then you both have to put
down your selfishness above what you
both want in order to make sure that the
family ends up successful yes i mean
primarily
sacrifices if you have kids
i'm gonna have to make that sacrifice
you just you just became an aunt today
oh really your mom just posted about it
oh yeah but she always posts and [ __ ]
yeah
i was gonna pick it back off pearl
because pearl's mate
i'm just excited about it
uh i was just gonna highlight something
that that pearl has said before in her
past streams or her reactions
that yeah i'm a huge condoner of free
will in your choices but just don't cry
about it complain about it later which
pearl has said it before like hey you
cry you chose that don't cry about it
later but the decisions how you want to
live your life you know
that's my only thing with people
yeah you should make your decisions how
you want to make them but i mean
i mean i feel like
i don't know i guess personally i'm not
like in a rush to make any crazy
decisions
also hey
sorry go ahead bro i mean yeah i don't
know you're good go ahead yeah i'm gonna
keep it a stat we say cry no um who who
are the main people that are like crying
about the state of like
relationships today though like let's
just keep your whole [ __ ] stuck
women
yeah women most men in divorce court
paternity tests paternity fraud
uh men
who self-delete men self-deletion
i think everyone complains yeah
let's just work on ourselves i don't
like
but go ahead pearls the part of working
on yourself is woman nature though part
of part of where pill is knowing woman's
nature how who they date hypergamy what
to do what not to do building yourself
to be the better man for yourself
um it it maybe it doesn't sound like you
have an experience with a lot of women
this isn't a shout out to mac but it
sounds like you need to get more into it
with the women as well to know and it
sounds like you got to build yourself a
little bit up more too because i
understand you went through something
like what do i have to put myself up for
i can just do me if it doesn't work out
it's cool so
yeah yeah
but you're also coming at it like from a
misunderstanding of not understanding
the red pill itself
well they don't exactly do a very good
job explaining themselves so
not saying at all
men suffer
heavily
what females suffer when it comes to
consequences of sex and when it comes to
around divorce court family court
stuff like that so all he's saying we
all have our choice
so you know what he's saying is
men who have been through it will come
together to try to prevent other men
from going through it that's all the
right things yeah yeah
well i mean it's more like a deterrent
but why don't you have it
you're right
don't stick your dick in dumb [ __ ]
yeah but you also gotta understand some
women can change mac
you
you're being very ignorant man how old
are you
i'm 22.
man got mad as hell quick
the way you come off in the way like i'm
experiencing like what you're saying
yeah is it it comes off as a place of
like authority and i'm telling you like
you don't have the life
like neither neither
neither do i like do i i just think it's
like i mean that's cool
just
yeah it doesn't sound like you do mac
i'm i'm sorry then like okay if she
switches up then like by definition
nation is pretty hard to [ __ ] spot so
we don't i just like
i mean i get it it's just
a few things it's like uh but then like
i mean we got
we got to try now here he's blue i'm
like no i'm just speaking my mind like
no one's attacking you here man i just
want to make sure that so no one's
attacking you
what i'm trying to help you
matt got pissed oh
i'm not
can i ask the question i i just i wasn't
pissed i'm just confused everyone's
gonna ask a question yeah i go
what is your guys's type besides like do
you all you want is someone that doesn't
argue with you or do you like have a
personality
don't say it like that don't do that
don't do that don't don't try to put us
in that
pearl she's your friend you're a person
i don't know what the difference is
no no no no no no listen no marcus go
ahead you go first brother go ahead
first
like so for me because i grew up latin
culture i grew up hispanic um so i just
want a woman who's not crazy who's
respectful who respects my boundaries
who can take a joke who can laugh
um she doesn't have to be like super fit
but she can be decently averagely fit
and um three times a week
yeah there you go
there you go
yeah she can work three times a week
yeah i knew she was gonna say that uh
yeah she's a decent cook she doesn't
have to be a great cook because
i like to cook because i grew up my
first job was being a cook and a chef
for a bit and and i don't i can teach
her to cook she can teach me some things
that's cool but she overall has to at
least know how to know better than rice
or ramen noodles or a cup of mac and
cheese she better know more than that
and then i feel like every adult yeah
and yeah and then on top of that she has
to get along with my family she doesn't
get along with my family there's going
to be she's going to be problems
that's a big automatic factor that i
noticed i never hear women say oh i'll
be cool with your mom or i'll be i'll be
close i'm close to my family i don't
hear a lot of women say that that's
missing in the dating market
someone that's close to their family
values and traditions see this is more
interesting to me than you saying like
you don't want someone to give you a
headache this is this clears it up a
little more
well i definitely don't want a headache
nobody no man wants a headache
i think it's just like getting along
with someone you don't want somebody to
argue
all we were trying to say is that men we
say don't give us a headache is the fact
the matter is if
all right
men are a lot more simpler than you are
so we don't go through the same
emotional and mental loopholes you do
for the same things that you would it's
always always saying like
like like my girl was one time asking me
like how can i do more to motivate you
and this that and the other it's like i
don't really need your motivation i need
your mind needs to protect me so it's
like i don't need you but for so much
because if i wasn't already confident
motivated you wouldn't be with me so all
we're saying is we don't need that much
from him and that's why we say that
yeah our checklist is much shorter brook
brook like pearl already knows this but
brooke our our men's checklist are much
more shorter like it's more simpler but
the things that we care about it equates
to what you girls care about it equates
that
yeah like for example let's say you all
right brooke how tall are you
five six
okay well let's say you guys got six
feet making 200k a year
six feet making 200k a year
um
works out so he has a good body okay he
doesn't need your money he doesn't need
you to protect him he built himself up
before he got with you because you're 26
years old so he doesn't need your
motivation your knowledge so what else
does he need you for
other than to cooperate with him submit
to him
you know what i'm saying like that's
what that's how men that's how it is
i i guess i just always thought of
dating of like
you have a homie that you really i mean
well i guess two if you don't factor in
kids it was always like she said
friends that you're really really gonna
get to hang out with all the time
i get it it just has a connotation and
i'm just like you know
i'm bad oh [ __ ]
marcus want me to go next
oh that's fine my bad i was i was
already done
i was already done okay
i mean
marcus actually hit probably like two
things that are on my list literally and
it's just you know it'll be able to like
my mother father that's pretty much it
right there you know be able to be
respectful
um just just be able to talk to me like
a civilized person if you can do that i
think we'll be gucci right there
and um you know just like i said just be
nice if you can do those things then
we're all good
that's simple like i said talk to me
like a civilized person that's all i'm
asking so when it comes to the whole you
know just not be submissive thing but
i'm talking about like just be
cooperative
if you have a grievance with me why not
with me specifically have you had
agreements with something
speak to me civilized do not come at me
angry about it just come to me and say
babe i need to talk to you about
something
all right here i come let's go shout out
that tv turn off your phone we about to
hash this out let's go it's that simple
and we've talked like civilized people
so that that's just my biggest thing
when it comes to that because i do
naturally get um more headaches when i
come off of work but that but i'm not
going to bring that anger towards you oh
she cut she kicked out
i like
yeah it's just really simple it's like
simple like that and um you know i like
to cook too so don't worry like if
there's a day you don't feel like
cooking i will cook that day especially
at the day off i'll definitely cook that
day yeah if it you know yeah right
or daily with the kids of course
yeah like the date like the day my bad
i'm sorry but like the days that i cook
that like the days that i cook i tell
her like don't walk in the kitchen let
me do my thing and the days that she's
in the kitchen she'll cook and then she
like she'll do her thing because i like
to do my cooking my way she likes to do
her cooking her way and then that's how
we just we communicate that way though
um marcus i'm gonna kick you off oh sure
no respectfully
kick off the token mexican i got you
i'll leave for marcus i'll leave for
marcus hold on oh that's respect right
there
oh much love that's a real one i got a
question all right that's back
go ahead
i'm sorry what's the killing i'm sorry i
can leave
i don't know you're already here
i don't know i know but this is like i
feel like you guys are more into this
okay what's your what's your question
all right so i heard on brooke kind of
asked the question earlier that question
was an answer
she said everything you're asking for
is it
is it reciprocal nobody no no no that's
a question
in terms of basically um all these guys
stating what they want you know i just
want you to look and i just want you to
do this
then break him up
she said um well she came on she spoke
she said everything you're asking me for
right now is it the other way around but
none of these guys seem to give a
response i mean respond and i'm just you
know i'm actually interested in what
what your response would be
any of the guys on the table
um yeah so
our ground of course like what you're
saying is there would be compromises but
if we were to carry the same standard if
i was agreeable towards her and
submissive towards her and what other
word that says cooper cooperation is
cool but if i was those things to her
she would just leave me because then i
would fall into the category of the
symptom if that was my general ground
rule there's nothing like we stated
earlier before there's nothing wrong
with the man admitting he's wrong there
and she had a better idea and then going
in her direction and then learning from
her and then leaving that we're talking
about general groundworks we're not just
sitting i didn't know she asked that
question um well i'm not talking we're
not talking about just all the time
concrete we're talking about just
general things if i was to be agreeable
to her if i was to be submissive to her
and that was my standard thing
that was the general thing we wouldn't
have a relationship because she would
leave
so that's that's what yeah
anybody else have to add to that
i'm not going to lie i agree with dc i
agree with dc
um
so what's it talking about what
we were all saying what we wanted
uh yeah
sorry scott
i mean
jones he's asking you jones oh yeah
clarify your question
all right all right no no the reason why
i personally asked you that question is
i just feel like a lot of people come in
a lot of people walk around regret it on
regurgitating on kevin samuel but real
life like real life real life [ __ ]
you know real life [ __ ] it's not like
that
it's really not like that i heard it
earlier you got to meet in the middle i
think that sounds more realistic
you know
and everyone's really like young here i
just think it's it's unrealistic in a
20-year marriage
to like
not think there's going to be middle
ground at some point
well the reason the reason why it's
gonna be
there's gonna be middle ground and
that's you sound kind of long
oh i'm sorry man
i apologize let me be close wait a
minute
okay
what i was trying to say is this
everybody keeps on talking about the
middle ground and what happens in this
and the other when you go to a job they
give you a description of what your job
and your role is
that's all we're doing we know everybody
knows in life that of course nothing is
black and white there are gray areas
there are middle grass to be met but
before you get to a middle ground of
something we have to have basic
descriptions right right
the only reason there's a gray area is
because black and white exists and
that's what we're doing we're laying out
that foundation
um
yeah i mean people keep on talking about
middle ground yeah that happens but
first that all we're doing is saying the
foundation and giving a description and
that's it that's all we did yeah and so
and if i can educate you a little bit
jones on my background
my father was the one who was actually
teaching me along the way so if anything
kevin samus could have got it from us if
anything because i was getting this
stuff before kevin saying
and and remember this too jones because
before kevin samuels a lot of what kevin
samuels is saying is what tommy
sotomayor was saying before kevin
samuels because uh royal tomasi uh tommy
sotomayor these guys are all saying that
before kevin samuels
then this then you can check the
timeline you can take it to the bank
all right that's that
now is it fair to say is it fair
is it fair to say west africa
we carry this thing that we call respect
where the wife actually listens to the
um husband don't matter
okay because bro because brooke is quick
because brooke is quick
is it good
is that what are you cooking what are
you cooking brooke i'm making a curry
oh sure okay so i'm going to ask that
again
that comes to respect
the culture of respect
africa west africans
asians
japanese is the epidemic of respect is
it fair to say that
i think human beings in general respect
human beings in general respect man
meaning like what if the husband says
yay the wife doesn't arrive
say that
i think what they're saying is like it's
it's cool to disagree just like don't
come out like wow like don't feel like
going the first place respectful
instagram or if you're in like a wendy's
like ma'am this is a wendy's don't be
yelling and stuff like this don't be
well now yeah because men don't want to
be embarrassed by their by their man i
mean women don't want to be embarrassed
by men and men don't want to be
embarrassed by their woman it just so
happens that we don't want for us men if
we we don't want our girls showing her
ass out on instagram my girlfriend
doesn't do that that's the reason why
she's my main chick
pearl knows this jade takeshi knows this
my girl doesn't do that kind of stuff
she doesn't push her body out there
she's not hooking up with other dudes
out there she's not out in the bar with
her girls anymore that much she barely
even was when i first dated her she
barely even went out to the bars of the
clubs at all if that she's not that kind
of woman like that and that happens in
western societies australia canada the
uk in america these are all westernized
civilizations now so much that because
of this feminist propaganda sexual
liberation contraceptives the list can
go on
jones we already answered the question
we we already
already made it we made this clear i i i
hear you die i hear you guys i just feel
like you can make it clear all you want
that still doesn't change the fact that
the middleweight is the way man you
could talk about dude
that's not what we're talking about
i listened to you yeah
something minutes just listened
just listen you guys sounds like you're
looking it sounds like you're looking
for slaves i don't know if you see a
delivery
hold on hold on hold on
no no incorrect i don't know like i said
i don't want your delivery
but as an active soldier i listen to you
and i give orders all day and you guys
sound like you're giving orders
no
i started in the military so no
at least how it came off to me though
like that's why i was kind of like no
you're just being ignorant jones
hey man
some of the stuff
we're not
not many of us are like saying like it
was like the content now that's been
fully digested and understand that
what's wrong it was something like
awkward like was saying if we were
passing by like it's a slightly busy
night we're all walking home and we just
like was over here and we would probably
like do like a little like look over the
shoulder maybe like a little bit
i just think instead of like jumping
conclusions take the time out to listen
and take notes that's what you would do
in school right you're in class
how about you listen maybe you could she
jumped in she jumped in the conclusions
and i was helping her out that's what
people wanted to do
god it sounded like you were barking
orders it's just that simple you stopped
all we did was stand here and say
directly abcd the same way how the
meteorologist says hey guys it's gonna
rain tomorrow it's gonna do this or
normally we see this normally we see
that that's all we did we didn't
barking orders is saying we didn't say
she had to do anything all we did was
sit here and give advice and critique
you know
if a doctor came and told you you need
to go and take this medicine you need to
go do this that and the other would you
be saying oh you're barking words at me
or would you just say oh the doctor's
just telling me things hey man hey man
when she puts up the video you can watch
it again all i need before i pro
yeah i'll go for an hour i listen
like i said maybe it's your delivery
because if you look in the chat i said
in the chat yo y'all sound like y'all
barking orders even when deleting no i
think that's your insecurity on it but
what's wrong with our delivery all we're
doing is speaking to we haven't said one
cuss word i haven't called one person a
name
i never said you did
did i oh my gosh i think i missed i was
gone for a second
yeah
yeah just said just jones wasn't really
listening to us he wasn't really hearing
that well but it's all right well i
don't i don't know what happened go on
pearl
because he's putting words into our
mouths and he's jumping inclusions in
our mouth because you weren't here
earlier what he was saying girl
so what did i put in him
yeah because because you're saying that
we were looking for slaves that we want
slaves and we're barking orders and
nobody said that the whole time you
literally said it it's recorded it's
it's recorded it's recorded
you're saying that's how it came off
right
no no ain't nobody looking for this
ain't 12 years of sleep this isn't jango
and chain
ain't nobody wants slaves you said you
were once active right
yes i'm very sure you understand the
difference between
somebody saying something that
somebody's saying it sounds like
well you did say it it's recorded
we're not looking for slaves when or did
it ever come out of our mouths
okay well
what i say well i think he said it sound
okay i don't i don't care enough about
this topic
um jones was just
okay well okay don't don't insult other
people on the panel i don't like that
that's not no no
this is this is my platform
i just don't like name calling i think
it's rude i don't know
right
no i don't okay okay i'm i'm gonna kick
everyone off except brooke so thanks for
coming on yeah i appreciate it
very nice to meet you guys
i'm sorry i just don't
i don't even know what they're arguing
about but i just it really rubs me the
wrong way when people use name calling i
don't like that i think they were just
like making up words
oh no did i kick off brooke
no way where did brook go
wait call wait call back in hold on
uh
i'm gonna remove
um i don't know where she went i think
her phone i think she's having like
wi-fi issues or something i just really
i don't oh there she's back i'm bad wait
is this like live right now yeah people
can see this yeah what
oh wait i didn't know that i thought
this was just for like funsies that
they're just talking to random people on
google
no
no this has been a live it's on my
youtube channel
no i just i really don't like name
calling it's not i just think it's
trashy and i don't care if you do that
off my platform but don't do that on my
platform i don't like that
i don't have the other guy i don't know
if the other guy did it too but that's
just not my deal
if if they say they want someone to like
not give them a headache or be
respectful
if they're just going to yell at people
they're not respectful
or call names you know well i this is a
little different because this is more of
like a debate format like that's kind of
what we do to discuss ideas
well yeah but you can like
present your ideas but you can't be rude
to someone
yeah well
i don't know that's that's a whole
nother conversation oh my gosh you know
this is what i wanted to tell you
um
oh my gosh um
the
the
um actually
maybe i should take this off the air but
i i think
that
it's interesting because in the red pill
in this space it seems like they think
all my friends
would think a certain way and i'm like
no my friends are very different
you know
i mean
i think it's like also different about
like who you usually hang out with so
maybe the type of people they usually
hang out with or that they interact with
are like
maybe they're a certain way or react a
certain way
um
and then maybe then i'd use i don't know
because i feel like
i don't know
i feel like what you grow up around and
the people you hang out with and like
i guess like the people you associate
yourself with like at work or
in your personal life kind of i mean
that makes you like
that kind of
creates how you think i guess
um if you're not exposed to different
areas or maybe you're not used to things
or if you don't believe it like you
don't have to talk to someone
differently than you
yeah
oh my gosh
what
um it says broke was just chilling and
it went to on
unsolicited lecturing
me
yeah where are you looking
oh you can see the comments section
oh
they were just trying to give her advice
and i asked for it hell yeah
i don't know it's
it's kind of
oh my gosh my head hurt after that i was
just like yeah i was just i i i
needed advice they literally asked for
my type and then started telling me how
to get a man
or they tell you how to get married and
you're like i don't want to get married
yeah they're like [ __ ]
yeah i always i always feel like that'll
change for you someday to be honest
it might i actually have a lot of
friends um who thought that way and then
they like met their the current person
they're dating and they changed their
mind so thank you
out of curiosity how old were they when
they changed their minds
um one of my friends is in her 30s
the other one i think is two or three
years older than me
so close to 30
i don't know that's very red pill
i don't know what that means
so the they have a concept that around
the age of like 27 to 35-ish is when a
girl
basically like changes her mind about
that stuff like all the girls that said
they didn't want to get married then all
the people want to get married but it's
also like girls that maybe didn't have
like a relationship that they
liked and then you find one that you're
like you're someone you're really into
and you're like oh i can see things
differently with them
yeah
no i'm sure that's part of it but it's
it's yeah it's just a concept in red
pill
yeah
i feel like the more you're thinking
about relationships though like
i don't know it's almost like the more
you over tend to overthink things
lol it's when we start to lose our
beauty sadly that's what one of the
comments said
ah in your 30s
yeah like late 20s early 30s depends on
the person though but
also i mean it depends on your lifestyle
and if you
have kids or not because sometimes it's
hard to like
get yourself back after kids oh
something
i've seen some hot moms
yeah but it's like the exception not the
rule
you know what i mean
yeah
um
the biological clock is always
undefeated
what kind of what kind of advice do you
give people said someone said they like
yours well i don't i don't even really
give advice on my channel because
i feel like you should have
i don't know how to put it
like if i was going to give relationship
advice shouldn't i be in a successful
relationship
you know but sometimes you can like see
things from the outside
yeah
yeah but
yeah i don't know i give some advice um
i wouldn't really give
the advice i give is more
i guess for people that want to get
married and like what men look for so um
just like i didn't realize that most men
are attracted to most women
and they're a lot less picky than us and
the stuff they care about is like
obviously what the guys were talking
about like agreeableness
yeah and like like fit feminine friendly
basically and i i never understood that
for a while
um
so if you want to get married try to be
those things
do you want to get married to me
oh my gosh i would love to find a male
version of you
i don't i don't like girls though
it says y'all know simping but i don't
think brooke is struggling thank you
i think you can still talk a bit
yeah exactly someone said i think you
can still talk and what you've learned
and how you apply it to your next
relationship i agree yeah thank you so
much relationship what have i learned
from my last relationship i hope you
learned a lot
oh my god don't
don't don't
um but oh my gosh he did you did you see
what i sent you i was like oh no
yeah
um
yeah next wild it's weird because like i
feel like if anyone ever did that to me
no one would ever send it to me because
like
i mean you just have so many people that
see you all the time
yeah no that's the thing
but it is what it is it's like
whatever
to be honest
i just was very surprised
i guess
yeah
um
okay i don't know i can't i don't really
see if i like listening or write as we
i
i was like don't say anything crazy just
because this is on the internet
i don't know i don't know what to what
to talk about now
i'm meal prepping oh my gosh i just put
a pizza in the oven well i'm about to i
just preheated the oven
i decided to try to be more healthy this
year
like everybody
yeah except i paid for it so now i have
to follow through
what did you pay for
um i paid for a personal trainer and a
nutritionist so now i'm following this
like official meal plan
oh yeah
yeah
um it sucks so far
i mean it doesn't suck but like now that
she told me i can't eat pizza rolls i've
really been craving pizza rolls
it's always when they tell you you can't
you want to do it more i know like i
haven't had them in so long but then
like i went to the store and i almost
bought a bag and i was like no
oh my god
you know what
i want
i want to lose like 20 pounds that's my
goal this year 20 pounds
you don't need to lose 20 pounds
have you gotten your like body fat
percentage yeah because i need to lose
20 pounds
[Laughter]
it's okay
i'm gonna just be really hot
you're already hot
okay but i want to be hotter
okay everybody must be hotter that's
fair i just
um
oh my gosh
oh yeah wait i have a good question
would you date a guy who's high
maintenance
define high maintenance
like
like see here
so for example
i
in high school i didn't have time to get
ready i had to blow dry bryce's hair so
that he looked good for school and i
would go to school with my hairline
oh gosh um
[Music]
uh
i
the guy i dated for like a week like a
second um
was more high maintenance than i
oh or also that and high maintenance of
the like
where
actually enough so you finish your
thought finish your thoughts i will say
okay this is what i this is what i think
like there's an ideal of what i'd look
for i'd prefer a guy that's more low
maintenance but like if that was the
only thing that was the only but
everything else was fine yeah that's
fine i date them does that make sense
yeah
do you have like a super specific type
do you think
yeah i know you said your five things
but like do you usually go for that when
you date someone
or do you like notice you spray you
stray from it
well i'm trying to think
i
i think that
i
i'll like i'll get rid of like one or
two things it's like i like the guy and
it's like
um one or two things does that make
sense
yeah
um but
let me think
but yeah i don't know if that makes
sense
but yeah if it's like it was just like
he doesn't have one thing on the list
and everything else is fine
you're compromising yeah no of course
like one year i didn't have every single
thing that i looked for and i dated him
yeah true true
so
it was should i there's a girl that
wants to come on should i let her on
um yeah she's cool she's cool i've met
her before she's not gonna
yeah the last chat i had to boot
everybody that was too much
hi
hi how are you
i'm good how are you i'm good i wanted
to have fun on youtube i just uh i did
my first live stream earlier and i was
like wow like you can hang out on the
internet and have a good time and then i
saw your title i was like i have a story
tell tell me what's your crazy dating
story oh man okay so it's a little bit
gross um not like crazy tmi because i
mean people be on the internet anyway so
they see some crazy stuff but this had
happened to me twice um and hopefully
some guy out there hears this and
doesn't do this to another woman
but i was getting intimate with two
different men on two different occasions
like years had gone by and these were
like and they were in their 20s
but both both men randomly
um spit on me when we were intimate they
spit on me
twice
no no
two different guys yeah
like years apart right like my my shirt
is off my top is off one guy did it then
years later the other one did it and
the first guy i like looked at him i'm
like why why did you do that he said i
thought you would like it i'm like
like you get off of prawn hub get off
the prawn i don't
[Applause]
anyway that's my crazy dating story
don't recommend stop watching pran
did you did you
did you end it right after that or did
you keep seeing him you're like you know
what i'll i like him i'll give him a
little leeway
no i was really young i i just thought
oh he made he made a really dumb mistake
okay this is not going to be the rest of
my life or my future or anything like
that but the other dude i was married to
him but we were this is like we barely
knew each other when we got married i
got married after three weeks so then he
did it and i was like
i i i'm starting to deduce that i think
young men are addicted to prawn i think
that's what's going on here
yeah wait so
oh oh they can't say uh oh okay i see
that yeah i thought it was like a
special you know website i gotcha oh no
no no
it's just the algorithm doesn't like it
when you say that
oh my gosh i can't believe that happened
to you twice you poor thing i didn't
think like statistically why would this
happen but i guess they're all watching
the same content but that's my story i
don't have anything else to say and i'm
hungry i just saw the title i was like
people need to hear this so that men can
stop spitting on women
especially if that's your wife like why
are you gonna spit on your wife bro
wait okay i have a question though i
have a question yeah you said you
weren't sexually attracted to your
husband right yeah no no definitely not
so how did how did that happen
if you were if you were dating for three
weeks like wouldn't you i'm just
confused okay right yeah okay so
no judgment i'm just no no it's okay i i
don't it's the internet i think they
know everything at this point so i had
met him when i was in military training
to be a combat medic um
but he was really sweet and for people
who don't know military training candy
is rare so he brought me candy and i was
like oh this guy is so sweet
um
but i ended up talking to him and i
wasn't attracted to him he asked me to
be his girlfriend the first time i told
him no i said let's wait because in
these military training environments
there's a lot of you know you're in
training you hook up you move on with
your life and i wasn't sure like where i
was at um but it it seemed logical to me
to get married that marriage was a good
decision for me in that
that state of my life
and um and so i married him but i i
didn't know that it wasn't attracted to
him um i did not experience true
attraction to a man until i was with my
fiance like my body physically responded
to him in a way that i'd never had
happen with a man but now that i have
that reference of what my body feels
like with a thank you
of what my body feels like with a man
that i'm attracted to i'm like oh okay
like those are the indicators i think
that's why young women end up in
relationships that they're not attracted
to guys because they have no idea
like how serious the drip drop can be is
what i think
i agree with that statement hmm that's
interesting i've never huh
that's really interesting
but that's crazy you're a risk taker
three weeks yeah high risk high reward
that's what i do with my life
it lasted five years he's he's cool i
mean if i ever get rich and he you know
he's like
half of your fame is due to me i'm like
you know what fine i'll give you some
cash
but i'll let you guys go i have to go
eat some dinner bye
okay thanks for coming on yeah thanks
for having me
okay i'm trying to stand this up
sorry wait hold on i'm gonna be right
back just wait one second okay i'm gonna
put my pizza in the oven okay i'm gonna
leave two then
oh for real well i i have to pee
well then no one will be on the stream
oh i can what do i how do you hold it
i don't know what to talk about
can you invite someone else on for two
minutes
no no i probably i should have this
dream it's actually so late i should go
to bed
i'm having what time is the day
it's like two in the morning i have this
problem where i've been staying up too
late streaming
yeah uh you're a while i go to bed at
like 11 now oh my gosh we should do this
again though the chat likes you
do they
yeah
thanks wait is this on your like channel
forever
yeah
did you do anything embarrassing
i don't know i don't go i don't know i
don't know i don't think so i think
you're fine
okay
but yeah you're forever on the channel
unless you really want me to take it
down that i will
okay next okay you can leave it up i
don't go on youtube it's just wild to me
oh my gosh
okay well i'll talk to you later
okay hey thanks for hanging out
thanks for i'm gonna call you in a
second i got other stuff to tell you oh
yeah cool okay okay
bye
okay guys
i'm ending the stream
thanks for watching
this is fun
i'm tired can